GET STARTED ON THIS SIDE OF THIS
WORLD WONDERFUL TUESDAY MORNING
ARE SLIGHT TEARING.
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SELECT A
SCHOOL STARTED OUT OVER.
THE COMMITTEE.
AND DEAL INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED --
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR BEING A PART OF
THIS FIRST MEETING OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
TODAY'S THE FIRST OF SEVERAL
HEARINGS AT PLAN TO HOLD AROUND
THE STATE. FOR THOSE OF OF YOU
WHO DON'T KNOW ME I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM FRAZIER.
AND SINCE COMING TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY TWELVE
I'VE MADE THOSE.
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ONE
OF MY PRIORITIES.
THIS YEAR I ASK ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON IF I COULD
ESTABLISH A SPECIAL COMMITTEE
JUST FOR THE IDG.
COMMUNITY.
SPEAKER RENDON GRACIOUSLY
GRANTED PERMISSION TO ESTABLISH
THIS COMMITTEE.
I AM HONORED THAT HE APPOINTED
ME CHAIRMAN.
AND I TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY
TO HEART.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THE ASSEMBLY IS LISTENING.
TO THIS COMMUNITY.
AND WANTS TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
WE WOULD BE LISTENING TO YOUR
IDEAS.
AND YOUR CONCERNS.
ANY OTHER THOUGHTS AND
SUGGESTIONS WE ARE OPEN.
TO BECAUSE YOU ARE THE EXPERTS.
SO A COMMITTEES ARE DIFFERENT
FROM STANDING LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES WE DON'T HOLD
HEARINGS ON PENDING LEGISLATION
BUT BUT WHAT WE DO.
IS A IN LISTENING TO YOU WE CAN.
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION WITH YOUR
INPUT.
WE ARE HERE TO SUPPORT YOU AND
HELP MOVE THE NEEDLE FORWARD.
BECAUSE IT IS BEEN FROZEN IN
TIME FOR TOO LONG.
I AM EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT ALL
THE SYSTEM TODAY AND HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE MOVING FORWARD.
WE HAVE ACT EXPERTS IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE FIELDS TESTIFYING TO
THE RULES.
PROGRAM SERVICES AND CHALLENGES.
I HOPE THAT AS WE HEAR TESTIMONY
WE WILL THE REV UP FOR THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
AS WE WRAP THIS ONE UP.
THE NUMBER OF RIGHT ID DE
POPULATION.
CONTINUES TO GROW AND WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
SERVICES THAT ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THIS POPULATION.
WITH ME TODAY A COUPLE MEMBERS
OF THE THIS SELECT COMMITTEE --
IF ANY OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
COMMENTS I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO SO NOW.
AND I THINK YOU MISSED SHARE --
PEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE I KNOW
YOU ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
SENSE OF PASSION --
THAT I SHARE AND I SHARE YOUR
OVERALL CONCERNED --
ABOUT WHAT ARE SOME DEFICIENCIES
IN IN THE OVERALL --
STATE SUPPORT.
NOT FOR THE DD COMMUNITY --
IN PARTICULAR I MEAN* TO
HEAR FROM THE DIRECTOR LEARN
MORE ABOUT HOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT --%
OPERATES IS THE SELECT COMMITTEE
PROCESS IS ONE THAT --
AFFORDS US THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
QUEUE IN A AND REALLY --
IT'S AND LEARN A LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY ABOUT ALL THE
NUANCES.
FUNNY HOW THE DEPARTMENT
OPERATES UP A ANECDOTALLY I'VE
EVER HEARD THAT REFERENCES TO
UNSPENT FINDS THIRTY FIVE TO
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS IN UNSPENT
FUNDS -- NOT.
NOT BECAUSE OF A LACK OF NEED.
BUT SOME CONCERNS AROUND A LACK
OF SERVICE PROVIDERS A LACK OF
SUPPORT STAFF.
I'M I HAIL FROM SAN MATEO COUNTY.
AND ANY KNOWLEDGE THAT I HAVE --
IN THIS ARENA.
WHICH UP ALL IT MADE IS RATHER.
LIMITED OUT COMES FROM WORK WITH
COMMUNITY GATE PATH WHICH IS OUR
OF LEADING.
UP A SERVICE PROVIDER IN THAT
COMMUNITY BUT I HAVE BECOME
ACUTELY AWARE OF JUST HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO FIND
PROVIDERS TO PAY PEOPLE.
WHAT THEY DESERVE IN SUCH A HIGH
COST AREA LIKE SAN MATEO COUNTY
OR LIKE THE BAY AREA --
AT LARGE SO THERE'S SOME BASIC
COST A ISSUES.
THERE --
THERE'S ALSO A RATE STUDY AS A
UNDER NG WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AT LOVE TO LEARN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT BUT THAT WILL
TAKE A LOOK AT A JUST THAT THE
COST VARIATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THERE'S AN ONGOING
ISSUE AROUND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH IS AT THAT AT CRISIS
LEVELS I IN THE BAY AREA AROUND
THE AROUND THE STATE --
IN OTHER AREAS IN THE STATE BUT
IT'S PARTICULARLY CUTE OF FOR
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY --
NOT INDIVIDUALS WHOSE UP PARENTS
ARE AGING AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS SO THE WHOLE PANOPLY OF
ISSUES HERE THAT I'M HOPING THAT
WE CAN.
HOW VIA THE SELECT COMMITTEE UP
I EXPLORE BUT JUST AS A NOTE OF
THANKS TO OUR THE CHAIR FOR YOUR?
YOUR UP YOUR OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON NOT ONLY FROM POLICY
PERSPECTIVE BUT DOES.
NOT MAKING THIS A MORAL ISSUE
THAT WE MUST DO BETTER ON IT
THIS IN THIS BUILDING.
SO WE WERE WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE
TO ALSO I'M DID ALL THE COMMENTS
ON WELL TO TO OUR CHAIR IN HIS
PASSION FOR THIS ISSUE.
AND I'M EXCITED TO BE PART OF
THIS COMMITTEE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND JUST REALLY
BRIEFLY WHEN I LOOK AT THE
MISSION STATEMENT --
BASICALLY IT'S STATES INTO AND
THAT THIS COMMITTEE WILL WORK TO
ENSURE THE RIGHTS AND DIGNITY OF
ALL PEOPLE WITH OUR INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND SHALL STRIVE TO ADVOCATE.
ON BEHALF --
BY PROMOTING PUBLIC AWARENESS
ABOUT THE NEEDS AND THE
ABILITIES OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES BUT ALSO --
THE I THINK THE REALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
LISTEN. TWO PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WILL ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO HEAR THEIR OPINIONS.
WHAT THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED ARM
AND LEARN FROM THAT BECAUSE
THAT'LL BE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US AS WE GO FORWARD
TRYING TO SPUR SHATTER THE
STIGMA AND ENCOURAGE BETTER PHAM
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND AND MORE --
SERVICES SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I'M EXCITED TO LEARN MORE
TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER SO AFTER THE
INTACCT INTRODUCTIONS WILL
HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME MORE MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE COME IS
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS BEING
AUGUST IS THE BUSY TIME OF YEAR
AFTER COMING OFF.
RECESS PEOPLE TRYING TO CATCH UP.
AND AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WATER TODAY HOPE THAT
MORE MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO ATTEND.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA START WITH
OUR FIRST.
PANELIST HOWARD DIRECTOR BARGAIN
I'M FORWARD.
AS OUR FIRST PANELIST WOULD YOU
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF TO THE
PANEL AND ALSO IN YOUR TITLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I NANCY
BARGE MEN --
DIRECTOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AND THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY -- AND
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
AND I APPRECIATED THAT
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO ALL GO AHEAD AND
GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW AND ALL.
ALL TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
ADDITIONAL ONES.
I'M AS WE'VE KIND OF FINISH
THROUGHOUT THIS MORNING --
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SERVICES SYSTEM AND TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE CONTEXT BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES.
I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
YOU THIS OVERVIEW AND TAKE YOU
BACK A LITTLE BIT IN TIME.
SO -- TWO
THE DEVELOPMENTAL --
SERVICE SYSTEM --
AS A DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES WE OPERATE ON IN
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE A PACKET
FOR YOU.
AND FOR THAT MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE I'M AND FOR THOSE THAT
WOULD BE INTERESTED ORGAN
ACTUALLY POSTED.
THE PACKET ONLINE SO WE'LL HAVE
IT ON OUR WEBSITE WHERE ALL THE
MATERIAL WILL BE AVAILABLE ON A
LINK.
I'M SO M. IN YOUR PACKET YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE AN OVERVIEW.
OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS YOU HAVE
THAT MAP BUT ON WITHIN THE FIRST
FEW PAGES WE ALSO HAVE OUR
SAFETY NET REPORT AND WE HAVE
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
ALL BE REFERRING BACK.
TO ON THROUGHOUT ON THE MORNING --
DDS IS RESPONSIBLE --
FOR UNDER THE LANHAM ACT ON TO
OVERSEE THE COORDINATION THE
PROVISION OF SERVICES FOR JUST
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
PROVIDING SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES THOSE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH A DIAGNOSIS
OF CEREBRAL PALSY INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY.
AUTISM ABSOLUTE EPILEPSY AND
ALSO RELATED CONDITIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT SETS BROAD POLICY
AND PROVIDE STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
ESTABLISHED SHE'D PRIORITIES
STANDARDS.
PROCEDURES WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES PROGRAM
IN WHICH WE OPERATE MONITORS
REVIEWS AND I VALUE RATES OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
BY WAY OF HISTORY THE CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS STARTED --
GOES BACK TO THE EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN FIFTIES IN ON CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IS A
DEVELOPMENTAL SORT OF STILL IN
OPERATION TODAY WHILE IT'S
CLOSING BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR --
IT WAS AND IS THE OLDEST
FACILITY IN OPERATION AND OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM GOING
BACK.
TO EIGHTEEN NINETY ONE IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN SIXTIES ON
PARENTS LEGISLATORS HAD TAKEN A
LOOK AT ENSURING THAT SERVICES
WERE GOING TO BE DELIVERED
DIFFERENTLY THAT WITHIN
INSTITUTIONS AND TAKING A LOOK
AT WHAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES WERE.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AB SIX
NINETY ONE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
ESTABLISHING TO PILOT REGIONAL
CENTERS WHICH ARE NOW.
FRANK D. LETTERMAN REGIONAL
CENTER AND GOLDEN GATE REGIONAL
CENTER WHICH IS LOCATED IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE LANHAM ACT CREATED A VISION
FOR A STRUCTURE OF A COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS.
CALIFORNIA ASSISTANCE PROVEN OUR
SYSTEM HAS REALLY PROVEN TO BE A
MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE NATION.
AND IS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS IN A
STATE CAN BE PROVIDED WITH AN
ENTITLEMENT SYSTEM.
THE LETTERMAN ACT STIPULATES
THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
LEGALLY ENTITLED --
TO A NUMBER OF RIGHTS INCLUDING
THE RIGHTS TO RECEIVE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS THAT FACILITATE
THEIR ABILITY TO LIVE IN THE
WRIST LEAST RESTRICTIVE.
SETTINGS IN THE COMMUNITY OF
THEIR CHOICE.
THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO
CONTINUE TO OF ALL.
AND WE CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT THOSE NEW IN MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE CHOICES THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL.
TODAY THE LANHAM ACT --
PROVIDE SERVICES THROUGH A
NETWORK OF TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND AGAIN IN EUROPE --
IN YOUR PACKET YOU HAVE A MAP OF
ALL REGIONAL CENTERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE LAW DICTATES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DDS.
AND THE RESULTS CENTERS HAVE
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
REGIONAL CENTERS PROVIDE
DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENTS DETERMINE
PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND CARE COORDINATION
AND CONTRACT WITH COMMUNION
PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE SERVICES.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES.
DECISIONS ARE MADE BASED ON THAT
THE NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL
FOCUSED ON ON THE PERSON AND NOT
AS OUTLINED IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAM PLAN.
BY DESIGN THE DEPARTMENT IS NOT
INVOLVED IN THE DIRECT ROLE IN
THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE IPP.
DDS CURRENTLY OPERATES AS A
STATE DEPARTMENT WE OPERATE
THREE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IN
THE STATE ONE COMMUNITY FACILITY
WE HAVE TO MOBILE CRISIS
FACILITIES AND OPERATE TO ACUTE
CRISIS STABILIZATION.
HOMES UNDER THE DEPARTMENTS --
SAFETY NET PLAN WE HAVE A PLAN
TO IT --
EXPANDS THE US STABILIZATION
HOMES IN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND A SAFETY NET PLAN
IS ALSO INCLUDED IN YOUR PACKET
AND AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
TODAY IN --
FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET FOR
SERVICE DELIVERY IN CALIFORNIA
IS SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH TWO POINT. NINE
BILLION IS AND FEDERAL FUNDS AND
REIMBURSEMENTS.
OVER THE LAST FIFTY YEARS THE
LANHAM ACT HAS HAD SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
IT'S INVOLVED IN HAS ALSO HAD
SOME CHALLENGES.
THIS INCLUDES SOME OF THE THE
CUTS THAT OCCURRED IN I'M DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION BACK IN
200-092-2000.
TWELVE SOME OF THESE CUTS
INCLUDED CHANGES IN ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR EARLY START SUSPEND
SUSPENSION AND LIMITATIONS TO
SOME OF THE PURCHASE OF SERVICES
TO INCLUDE SOCIAL RACK CAMP.
AND ALSO ON RESPITE.
THERE'S ALSO REDUCTIONS TO
WRIGGLE CENTER OPERATIONS THERE
WAS I'M SEPARATE FREEZERS
INCREASING PARENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
FOCUS ON CHANGING AND CLOSING
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND
MAJOR EFFORTS TO INCREASE
FEDERAL FUNDING.
CHANGES IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM IS NOW IN A
PRETTY AND AND SIGNIFICANT
IMPORTANT ERA OF CHANGE AND
WE'RE SEEING THAT SIGNIFICANT
TRANSITION OUR SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
I'M WE HAD SAUCE CHANGES
OCCURRING IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
IN THE REDUCTION IN CHANGES OF
THE CLOSURE OF DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
LAST PERSON FROM AGNES
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
I MOVED FROM --
THAT --
STATE OPERATED FACILITY FOURTEEN
LETTERMAN DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
ALSO CLOSED YOU DO HAVE IN YOUR
PACKET THERE'S A CHART THAT
REFLECTS.
I'M FOR PRIOR YEARS AND I CAN
AND GIVE YOU THE PAGE NUMBER IF
YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO JUST TAKE A LOOK AT THE
CHANGES OF THE DECLINE IN THE
NUMBER OF DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN THE POPULATION OVER THE YEARS.
AND IF YOU'LL JUST GIVE ME A
MOMENT I CAN EVEN GIVE YOU THE
REFERENCE OF THAT PAGE --
SO YOU CAN SEE ON PAGE THREE
PROMPTED THE CHANGES AS FAR AS
THE POPULATION WITHIN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS AND THEN
YOU ALSO SEE ON PAGE.
FOUR WHERE YOU'RE SEEING THE
INCREASE IN THE REGIONAL CENTER
POPULATION.
SO IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AS A
THERE IS A MORATORIUM OF
EMISSIONS AND ALL DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AND THIS IS A IMPORTANT
TIME IN THE CHANGES OF OUR
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
OF NOTE IS BECAUSE AT THAT POINT
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX DEEDS BOTH WITH THE
BEHAVIOR CHALLENGES AS WELL AS
MEDICAL NEEDS.
WERE NO LONGER ADMITTED INTO A
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
THIS WAS REALLY THE FOCUS THEN
ON LOOKING AT HOW ARE WE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX DEEDS.
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY SERVICE
SYSTEM WE STARTED THE NEW MODELS
OF SERVICE THAT WERE BEING
DEVELOPED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE NEEDS --
INTO --
THOUSAND THIRTEEN UNDER THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
THERE IS A CREATION OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER TASK FORCE
TO FOCUS ON INFORMING US ON WHAT
WAS GOING TO BE THE FUTURE FOR
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS --
SHORTLY BEHIND THAT WAS ONCE IT
WAS DEFINED AS FAR AS THE FUTURE
PLAN FOR THE CLOSURE OF THE
REMAINING DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
THE CHANGE IN THE FOCUS OF THE
WORK OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS TASK FORCE.
FOCUSED ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SERVICES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT IS A
SERVICE DELIVERY AND CAN --
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THE
PRIORITY AREAS WHERE THE
PRESSURES AND WHAT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AS FAR AS
ADDRESSING SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS.
MOVING FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
CHANGES IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
AND THERE'S A LAW THAT WAS
SIGNED.
AS FAR AS MOVING FORWARD WITH
THAT SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT WHILE
IT'S TAKEN A NUMBER OF YEARS.
ON WE ARE IN A PLACE WHERE WE'RE
GONNA SEE IMPLEMENTATION BY THE
END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
ON SELF DETERMINATION AS
OFFERING INDIVIDUALS REALLY THE
FREEDOM AND THE ABILITY TO
MANAGE IN THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
MANAGING THEIR CONTROLS AND
THEIR BUDGETS AS FAR AS HOW THEY
WANT.
TO CHOOSE THAT SERVICES THEY
WANT TO HAVE WITHIN THEIR LIFE.
ALSO TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE
SAW THE EMPLOYMENT FIRST POLICY
THAT WAS PASSED IN IS NOW UNDER
THE LANHAM ACT.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN GOES THERE IS A RELEASE
OF THE NEW FEDERAL RULE ON FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
HOMING COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
MUCH.
ON COMPLIANCE WOULD NEED TO BE
ON AVAILABLE NEEDS TO BE MET BY
STATE IN THE U. S. THAT HAS
REIMBURSEMENT BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR H. CBS.
ARM FUNDING AND SO WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR TRANSITION
PLANNING.
AND THE REQUIREMENT OF THAT IS
IN.
TWENTY THAT IS I CAN A FRIGGIN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE FULL
COMPLIANCE FOR THE H. CBS FINAL
RULE.
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN AS AND MENTION
WE MOVE THE LAST PERSON FROM
LETTERMAN DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
ON BUT WE ARE ALSO IN THOSE
FINAL STAGES OF CLOSING OF THREE
REMAINING SO NOW MY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FAIRVIEW AND
PORTERVILLE WE WOULD SEE LAST
PERSON MOVE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN M. WITH A
NO LATER TO CLOSURE.
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE WE
ONLY HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY INDIVIDUALS REMAINING IN
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER THAT
WOULD BE CLOSING.
I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU JUST A A
PERSPECTIVE AS FAR AS THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE.
AND WHY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US AS A SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS AND UNDERSTANDING
BECAUSE AS WE'RE LOOKING AND
DEVELOPING SERVICES AND HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
POPULATION THAT WERE SURVEYED
TODAY BUT ALSO THE POPULATION
THAT WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT
SERVING IN THE FUTURE.
I'M I HAD MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
SERVE THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WE SERVE WITHIN
OUR POPULATION. 39% ARE HISPANIC
32% ARE WHITE 9% ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
AND THE REST ARE WITHIN THE
DIFFERENT AND ETHNICITIES WE DO
HAVE A VERY VERY DIVERSE
POPULATION WE HAVE TWENTY THREE
DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES AND OUR
POPULATION THAT WERE IDENTIFYING
SPEAKS ABOUT FORTY FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES. 48% OF THE
CONSUMER POPULATION IS UNDER THE
AGE OF 2238% OF OUR POPULATION
HAS A DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM. 80%
OF THE POPULATION LIVE AT HOME
OR WITH THEIR FAMILY OR IN THEIR
OWN INDEPENDENT LIVING ON
SETTING.
WITHIN THAT THE CHANGES WE ARE
SEEING ABOUT THIRTEEN TO
FOURTEEN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM EACH YEAR.
SO SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
CURRENT YEAR WE'VE SEEN A 42%
INCREASE IN OUR POPULATION.
SIZE OF REGIONAL CENTERS VERY
BETWEEN THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED AS
THE SMALLEST TO THE LARGEST
BEING.
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND YEP AN
ETHNICITY IS ALSO CHANGING WHERE
WE'RE SEEING A SHIFT WORK. TEN
YEARS AGO THIS SUMMER TO THE
CALIFORNIA ON DEMOGRAPHICS THAT
WE'RE SEEING CHANGES IS THAT 40%
OF THE INDIVIDUALS OF THE
POPULATION WAS WHITE BACK AND A
TEN YEARS AGO REPRESENTING.
THIRTEEN AT 32% TODAY WHERE THIS
IS CHANGING OUR HISPANIC
POPULATION NEXT INCREASING WHICH
IS CHANGING FROM 33% 239%.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT AS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE AN IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION REGARDING THE
INEQUITIES IN SPENDING WITHIN
THE DIFFERENT ON POPULATIONS
BETWEEN WHITE AND NOT WHITE AND
NON WHITE.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT THE
GROWTH WITHIN THE POPULATION WE
ALSO KNOW THAT 50% OF THE
HISPANIC POPULATION WITH AND AND
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM IS
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO WERE
ALSO SEEN SIGNIFICANT CHANGES AS
FAR AS THE GROWTH.
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM. TEN
YEARS AGO APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS OF
OUR POPULATION NIGHT
REPRESENTING 19%.
I'M HAD AUTISM TODAY WE HAVE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
REPRESENTING THAT.
THIRTY EIGHT I'M PERCENT HAVE A
A A DIAGNOSIS OF AUTISM.
OF NOTE IS THAT 80% OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AYE
REGIONAL CENTERS CONSUMERS THAT
HAVE AUTISM. 80% AS I SAID ARE
UNDER THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO SO
IT'S WORTH TAKING A LOOK AT
DEVELOPING RESOURCES WHAT WE DO
AS A A DEPARTMENT AND WHAT WE DO
IN WORKING WITH OUR COMMUNITY IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT OTHER PRESSURES
WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
BUT ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT HOW
WAS THE FACE OF THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE SERVING HOW IS THAT
CHANGING AND LOOKING FORWARD TO
HOW WE CAN BEST SUPPORT THEIR
NEEDS IN THE COMMUNITY.
I'M YOU ALSO HAVE AVAILABLE FOR
ADDITIONAL AND DATA AND AND
FACTS ABOUT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE SERVE IS AND THE FACT
BOOK THAT IS A PART OF YOUR
PACKET TODAY.
IN RECENT YEARS LEGEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RESTORE SOME OF THE
THE CUTS THAT OCCURRED DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION.
ON SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO BE ADDRESSED IS THE
STATEWIDE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED OVER THE
YEARS.
AND THEN ALSO WITH THE PASSAGE
OF AB EX TWO ONE THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME RESTORATION AS FAR SOME
SERVICES TO INCLUDE --
ADDRESSING OUR EARLY START AS
THE RESPITE SERVICES AND SOME OF
THAT I'M RIGHT IDENTIFYING HOW
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD FORWARD WITH
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WE STILL HEAR FROM OUR
STAKEHOLDERS CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES WITH THAT OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I CONTINUE TO SAY
OVER AND OVER IS THAT WE ARE A
SYSTEM OF PARTNERS. ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE DO
IS WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT.
AS PART OF OUR FOCUS AND MOVING
FORWARD WITH A PLAN FOR HOW WE
ADDRESS SERVICES IS LISTEN TO
WHAT THOSE CONCERNS ARE.
WE'RE HEARING ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY FOR FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY IN OUR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES UMPTEEN ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
WE'RE HEARING THAT THE BAND FOR
INCREASED SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH VERY COMPLEX
NEEDS PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH
VERY SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIOR
CHALLENGES WE SEE THAT
PARTICULARLY WITH INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE.
ARE YOUNGER WITH AUTISM WITH
HAVE COCOA OUR CURRENT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
WE WERE ALSO HEARING THAT THE
COMMUNITY BASED IN STATE
OPERATED SERVICES AN OPERATION
MAY NEED TO BE INCREASED OVER
TIME WE CONTINUE TO ASSESS.
OUR SAFETY NET TO SEE HOW WE CAN
CONTINUE TO EXPAND AND SUPPORT
THE COMPLEX NEEDS --
WE'RE ALSO --
ADDRESSING THAT THE QUESTION AS
FAR AS THE RATE STUDY BUT THE
RATE STUDY IS DUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PART OF THE
RATE STUDY IS THAT WE NEEDED TO
DO -- I RATE
SURVEY OF SERVICE PROVIDERS --
WE HAD IT WORKING WITH OUR
CONSULTANTS THAT IS DOING THE
SURVEY.
THE TARGET WAS TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE SAMPLE OF ABOUT 40% I'M
I'M I'M PLEASED TO REPORT TODAY
THAT ACTUALLY OUR COMMUNITY HAS
JUST DONE A PHENOMENAL JOB.
AND MORE ABOUT --
WERE VERY VERY CLOSE 250%
RESPONSE RATE --
WATCHES AS VERY INCREDIBLE AND I
I REALLY HAVE TO COMMIT OUR
COMMANDER COMMUNITY FOR FOR
BEING RESPONSIVE TO THAT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE FOCUSING ON
PRIMARILY ON ON WORKING AGAIN
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS TAKING A
LOOK AT COMPLETING THE SAFE
TRANSITION OF EVERYBODY.
WITHIN A DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER ON
COMPLETING THE RATE STUDY
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE
INEQUITIES IN SPENDING
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE SERVICE
DELIVERY NEEDS.
I'M WORKING WITH REGIONAL
CENTERS IN THE COMMUNITY AS FAR
AS DEVELOPING THOSE NEEDED
SERVICES AND TARGETED AREAS.
ON FURTHERING SOME OF THE
EFFORTS ON INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND ALSO
MAKING SURE WE'RE TAKING A LOOK
AT HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THE
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO ASSESS HOW WE
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TO OUR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND AGAIN BEING ABLE TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND AND IDENTIFYING
THE PLAN FOR THE FUTURE --
I CONTINUE TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND
SEEING HOW WE CAN BEST ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDE YOU INFORMATION WHILE
YOU DO YOUR IMPORTANT WORK.
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS MAKE YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL
[inaudible]
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW.
NAM I'M STILL DIGESTING ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION LET ME JUST SIT
YOU MENTION THE RATE STUDY AND I
REFERENCED IN MY OPENING REMARKS.
SO MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN THE
RATE STUDY WILL BE COMPLETED
WHAT DO YOU [inaudible]
ANTICIPATE WILL COME FROM THAT
RATE STUDY MEET WE DON'T DO
STUDIES JUST TO STAY WHY BECAUSE
WE SORT OF DO SOMETIMES JUST
STUDY THINGS AND DON'T ACT.
BUT WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE DOING
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT IS
SURFACED IN THE RATE STUDY AND
WHAT A KIND OF AUTONOMY DO YOU
HAVE AS THE DIRECTOR. TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS SIZE YOU SEE
APPROPRIATE OR WILL THAT REALLY
LAY AND BACK IN OUR LAP HOW DO
YOU VIEW THAT.
I THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION A
COUPLE THINGS I'D LIKE TO JUST
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
AGAIN THE PROCESS IN WHICH WERE
ALSO WORKING THROUGH THE RATE
STUDY -- I
MENTIONED THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE ON THE FOCUS
AREAS WITHIN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TASK FORCE INCLUDES
LOOKING AT THE RATES.
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR RATE WORK GROUP AND THAT
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES TASK FORCE.
TO IBM TO INFORM US ON WHAT THAT
THE ACTUAL SURVEY WOULD LOOK
LIKE SO WE'VE WE'RE ABLE TO PUT
THAT FORWARD NAY THEM WORKING
WITH OUR CONTRACTOR.
SO THAT INFORMATION WILL THEN
COME WE WILL GO AHEAD AND AND
WORK WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION.
I'M AND PRESENT THE INFORMATION
TO THE LEGISLATURE SO IT DOES GO
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE WE WILL
BE ABLE.
TO I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CAME
UP.
THROUGH THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
HAD WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN
THOSE.
DIAZ TASK FORCE TO SHORTEN TO
USE AN ACRONYM IF I MAY.
UM WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF ALSO
DOING A FAMILY SURVEY LISTENING
TO THE FAMILIES IN ADDITION AND
SAYING WELL WHAT ARE THE
IMPORTANT OUTCOMES SO WE JUST
RECENTLY DID AN AMENDMENT TO THE
CONTRACT.
OR FINALIZING THAT TO GO AHEAD
AND HAVE A SURVEY THAT'S GOING
TO GO OUT TO FAMILIES TO ALSO
HAVE THAT PIECE SO TOGETHER WITH
ALL OF THAT.
WE WILL THEN TAKE WILL TAKE IT
DIGEST IT ALSO BRING THAT BACK
WITHIN OUR DEVELOPMENT SERVICES --
WORK GROUP AND THEN WE WILL AND
BE REPORTING THAT OUT I'M BY
DESIGN --
EARLY PART OF THIS NEXT YEAR
[inaudible]
ENGLISH IS.
SOME MEMORABLE KALINKA JUST
REALLY QUICKLY --
IN YOUR TESTIMONY YOU MENTIONED --
THE DIFFERENT FACTIONS OF YOUR
WHOLE DEPARTMENT AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT.
THINGS THERE'S A LOT THERE.
WHAT IS JUST FROM MY KNOWLEDGE
OF CRISIS HOME OR AN ACUTE
CRISIS HOME?
VERSUS THE STABILIZATION TEAMS
AND DIRECT YOU KNOW HOW THOSE
WORK ANA BOTH THANK YOU.
SO WITHIN THEIR REGIONAL CENTERS
AND AGAIN TWENTY ONE REGIONAL
CENTERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PAY ON A
BROAD RANGE OF SERVICES AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES.
I'M WITH THE AND THERE I'M
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THERE ARE TIMES
HOWEVER THAT SOME OF THE NEEDS
MAY BE BEYOND SOME OF THE
CAPACITY WITHIN THE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED WHETHER IT'S
WITHIN --
THAT RESULTS CENTER SERVICES BUT
ALSO SOMETIMES EVEN WITHIN SOME
OF THE THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES.
WE WE HAVE A GREAT PARTNERS
WITHIN THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
IN IN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
ISSUES BUT WE ALSO UNDERSTAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
MAY HAVE SPECIAL AND DIFFERENT
NEEDS SO PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS
THROUGH THE SAFETY NETWORK AS
FAR AS ST HOW DO WE SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE MOST
COMPLEX NEEDS.
CONCERNS OF THE FACT THAT WE ARE
MOVING INDIVIDUALS TO THE
COMMUNITY WAS SAYING THE STATE
PLAYS A ROLE IN IMPORTANT ROLE
OF SUPPORTING INDIVIDUALS AND SO.
QUITE A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN WE
ANNOUNCED THE CLOSURES OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IT WAS
WITH --
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
STILL GOING TO BE SOME LIMITED
OPERATION WITHIN THE STATE ONES
ONE WAS WITH FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT WERE A PART OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BUT THE OTHER WAS WITH SOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE VERY
COMPLEX BEHAVIOR CHALLENGES
AGAIN INDIVIDUALS TYPICALLY WITH
CO OCCURRING NEEDS.
AND PART OF THAT WAS THEN THE
STABILIZATION CRISIS
STABILIZATION VERY SMALL SO NO
MORE THAN FIVE INDIVIDUALS
LIMITED TO WHERE THERE'S A
PROFESSIONALS AND WE HAVE A VERY --
CUT COMPLEMENT TO PROFESSIONALS
WORKING WITHIN THE STATE THAT
INCLUDES PSYCHOLOGIST SITE TAX
NURSES PHYSICIANS THAT WILL WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS TO ASSIST.
YOU KNOW FROM --
PHARMACOLOGY SO THE MEDICATIONS
BUT MORE ANA A VERY POSITIVE
INFORMED APPROACH IN MAKING SURE
THAT THE PERSON HAS.
BEEN NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM STABILIZE TRANSITION BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY.
IT IS TIME LIMITED IT'S NO MORE
THAN THIRTEEN MONTHS AND THE
STATE OPERATED SO IT'S A
RESIDENTIAL SETTING CURRENTLY AT
TO DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IS ONE
IS THAT CINEMA. ONE IS AT
FAIRVIEW BUT BE BECAUSE WE'RE
CLOSING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING THOSE SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY.
AS OVER THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS
THOSE SERVICES WILL BE MOVING TO
THE COMMUNITY.
IN ADDITION WE ESTABLISHED A
SPACE -- A
MOBILE CRISIS TEAM SO AGAIN A
SIMILAR COMPLEMENT OF
PROFESSIONALS THAT THAT ARE NOT
ONLY -- THEY
DON'T JUST WORK WITHIN A
RESIDENTIAL SETTING THEY CAN GO
TO THE COMMUNITY WHERE THE
PERSON KNOWS TO HELP STABILIZE
THE SITUATION.
ON TO MITIGATE THE RISK OF THE
INDIVIDUAL GOING TO A
RESTRICTIVE SETTING MAYBE AND
THAT BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CENTER OR
GOING TO A INSTITUTE FOR MENTAL
DISEASES THAT MAY BE RESTRICTIVE
AND NOT ABLE.
TO I MEET THEIR IMMEDIATE NEED
SO THE FIRST PRIORITY OF
STABILIZE A PERSON IN THEIR OWN
HOME WHERE THEY'RE CURRENTLY
LIVING I'M AND THAT WOULD BE THE
INTENT OF THE MOBILE ACUTE
CRISIS TEAM AND THEN.
IN THE EVENT THAT THAT CANNOT
OCCUR THEN IT --
THEY WOULD BE EXPLORING THE
WE'RE REDUCING THE RELIANCE ON
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE BUILDING THE CAPACITY
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE SMALLER
SETTING SOME STATE OPERATED SOME
REGIONAL CENTER DRIVEN.
THANK YOU.
MERELY QUESTIONS OF PAL.
DOCTOR I WANT TO THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE OF A REAL GOOD
RELATIONSHIP ON PARTNERING WITH
THIS COMMITTEE ON HOW WE CAN.
HELP EACH OTHER --
MOVE FORWARD TO THE PEOPLE THAT
WE CARE ABOUT THE MOST AND AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
YOU KNOW IS GLARINGLY --
PARENT IS.
OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED MORE FUNDING
BECAUSE YOUR CENSUS IS GROWING.
AND THE ABILITY TO LOVE FOR
PROVIDERS AND IT MAY HAVE TO BE
A CAREER CHOICE FOR SOME PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THE CONSISTENCY ISN'T
IT BETTER NEEDED BY SOME OF THE
YOUR CONSUMERS --
SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO HOW
WE CAN PARTNER AND AND MAKE IT A
BETTER --
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU AND US TO TO
US ARE THE PEOPLE THAT WE DO
CARE SO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND AND I CAN SAY WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS TO HAVE SIX YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD
TO ON OUR SECOND PANEL THAT WILL
BE -- MARK
EXCUSE ME YET MARK NEWTON --
THE DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
AND SONYA A PANIC OF A SENIOR
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE LA NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WAS LEFT THIS HAVE THE LA
NO -- AS
PART OF OUR PANELISTS
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M SONYA PADDICK FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND AS YOU NOTED THIS IS MY
COLLEAGUE MARTIN IT MARK NEWTON
DEPUTY.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AT THE LA
AUTO.
I WE'VE BEEN ASKED INVITED HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW ABOUT THE DDS BUDGET
AND DISCUSS SOME OF THE RECENT
BUDGET ACTIONS AND HISTORICAL
TRENDS.
AND YOU SHOULD HAVE A HANDOUTS
FROM OUR OFFICE --
THAT LOOKS LIKE.
IN ALL DISPUTES OF FOLLOWING
ALONG -- TO
THE STRUCTURE OF THIS HANDOUT.
SO PAGE ONE PROVIDES A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF WHAT I'LL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT A FIRST TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE BASICS OF THE
DTS BUDGET AND THEN --
BRIEFLY DISCUSS HOW THE CLOSURE
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
WILL IMPACT THE DDS BUDGET AND
THEN TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THE
RECENT ACTIONS OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND SOME OF THE FUTURE FISCAL
CHALLENGES LOOKING AHEAD I'LL
TRY NOT TO REPEAT --
TOO MUCH OF WHAT DIRECTOR BARGE
BEEN PRESENTED --
BUT ALL OF MY COMMENTS WILL BE
FROM SERVE A FISCAL PERSPECTIVE.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO OF THE
HAND OUT.
THE CURRENT DDS BUDGET IN.
TWENTY IS AT A RECORD HIGH OF
SEVEN POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
AND ABOUT 61% OF THIS COMES FROM
IF YOU ACTUALLY TURNED TO THE
FIGURE ON PAGE THREE YOU'LL NOTE
THAT SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN
RECENT YEARS IN THE DDS BUDGET
YOU'LL SEE THERE WAS SORT OF A
STALL.
WHEN BUDGET CUTS HAD TO BE MADE
DURING THE RECESSION?
AND YOU ALSO NOTE THESE RAPID
INCREASE IN CASE LOW GROWTH BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
GROWTH IN THE DDS BUDGET
ACTUALLY OUT PIECES GROWTH IN
THE DDS CASELOAD AND THIS IS IN
PART -- DUE
TO CHANGES IN IN UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES IT'S ALSO DUE IN LARGE
PART.
TO THE STATEWIDE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES WHICH THE STATE HAS
FUNDED FOR THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
IN THE DTS SYSTEM.
THE DEPARTMENT RECEIVES ITS
FUNDING FROM THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUND AS WELL AS FROM FEDERAL
FUNDS AND IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
FOUR YOU'LL SEE THE RELATIVE
SHARES OF GENERAL FUND IN
FEDERAL FUND --
FEDERAL FUNDS OVER THE PAST A
NUMBER OF YEARS --
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE PROMOTE
PROVIDED PRIMARILY IN THE FORM
OF REIMBURSEMENTS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR MEDICAID AND
MEDICAID WAIVER RELATED SERVICES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT --
HELPS PROVIDE THROUGH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
YOU'LL KNOW IN THE FIGURE ON
PAGE FOUR THAT AGAIN --
AS DIRECTOR PARCHMAN NOTED THE
THE RELATIVE BURDEN ON THE
GENERAL FUND WAS REDUCED DURING
THE RECESSION WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
SINCE THAT TIME HOWEVER GENERAL
FUND GROWTH HAS OUTPACED GROWTH --
FROM FEDERAL SOURCES OF FUNDING.
IF YOU'LL TURN TO PAGE FIVE OF
THIS DISCUSS THE TWO MAJOR
COMPONENTS OF THE DDS --
BUDGET THESE ARE THE SAME
COMPONENTS THAT DIRECTOR
BURGEONING DISCUSS BUT WILL
AGAIN TAKE A LOOK THROUGH FISCAL
LANDS -- THE
FIRST MAJOR COMPONENT AS THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM WHICH CAN
PROVIDES THE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES FOR DTS CONSUMERS.
THE REGIONAL CENTER BUDGET IS
COMPRISED OF AN OPERATIONS
BUDGETS OPERATIONS BUDGET FOR
THE REGIONAL CENTERS THEMSELVES
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING --
FOR SERVICE COORDINATOR STAFF
AND THE LIKE.
I'M AND IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICE BUDGET AND
THIS IS REALLY WHERE.
THE BULK OF THE DDS BUDGET
ALLIES MORE THAN 80% OF THE
TOTAL DDS BUDGET IS IN THE
PURCHASE OF SERVICES.
FROM A NETWORK OF MORE THAN
FORTY THOUSAND VENDORS ACROSS
THE STATE WHO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES TO CONSUMERS.
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT BEFORE
REGIONAL CENTERS CAN PAY FOR
THESE SERVICES DIRECTLY THEY
MUST FIRST EXHAUST.
ANY -- QUOTE
UNQUOTE GENERIC SOURCES OF
FUNDING SO THIS MAY INCLUDE
OTHER PUBLIC SOURCES OF FUNDING
LIKE MEDI CAL.
OR SERVICES PROVIDED BY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND ALSO PRIVATE SOURCES
OF FUNDING SUCH AS A PERSON'S OR
FAMILIES --
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE.
THE OTHER MAJOR COMPONENT OF THE
DDS BUDGET OUR THE STATE
OPERATED RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMUNITY FACILITIES.
THIS IS MADE UP OF THE THREE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS THAT WILL
BE CLOSING OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS CURRENTLY THERE BUDGET IS
CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
IT ALSO IS MADE UP OF THE
FACILITIES THAT WILL NOT BE
CLOSING SO THAT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OPERATES A SECURE
TREATMENT PROGRAM AT THE
PORTERVILLE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER
AS WELL AS COMMUNITY BUT SORRY
CANYON SPRINGS COMMUNITY
FACILITY.
THESE TWO FACILITIES WILL REMAIN
OPEN INDEFINITELY AND CURRENTLY
COST ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS WITH MOST OF THE
FUNDING COMING FROM THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND.
FINALLY THERE ARE THE SAFETY NET
AND CRISIS SERVICES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED.
A PARTICULARLY AS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS CLOSE AND
THE STATE HAS TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES OUT IN COMMUNITY BASED
FACILITIES --
THERE IT'LL BE IMPORTANT TO PAY
ATTENTION --
TO MAKING SURE THERE ARE ENOUGH
RESOURCES FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SEVEN WE'D
LIKE TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS THE
IMPACT THAT THE CLOSURE OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS WILL HAVE
ON THE DTS BUDGET.
IT'S GENERALLY UNDERSTOOD THAT
IT'S LESS EXPENSIVE TO SERVE
PEOPLE IN COMMUNITY SETTINGS
THAN IT IS TO RUN.
INSTITUTIONS --
HOWEVER AND THERE ARE SOME
SIGNIFICANT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH CLOSING THESE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS --
THE FIRST ARE THE COMMUNITY
PLACEMENT COSTS OF THIS DOES A
DTS HAS BEEN PROVIDED --
FUNDING SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING OVER THE PAST NUMBER OF
YEARS TO BEGIN DEVELOPING
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOVING.
OUT OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
IN IN INTO COMMUNITY HOMES.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE TO PAY FOR
JUST THE CUT COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH TRANSITIONING THOSE FOLKS
INTO THE COMMUNITY.
THERE'S ALSO THE COST TO DEVELOP
THE SAFETY NET IN THE COMMUNITY
NOW THAT DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS
WILL NO LONGER BE THAT PLACE OF
LAST RESORT FOR CONSUMERS IN
CRISIS.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE.
EIGHT WE DO OUR OFFICE DOES
ESTIMATE HOWEVER THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME NET SAVINGS TO THE
SYSTEM ONCE THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS ARE FINALLY CLOSED.
WE ESTIMATE THAT IN TERMS OF
OPERATIONAL COSTS THE STATE
COULD SAVE UP TO A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AT MOST FROM THE
GENERAL FUND RELATIVE TO THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET ONCE
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS ARE
CLOSED.
THERE'S ALSO THE POSSIBILITY
THAT REVENUES COULD BE RAISED
THROUGH THE SET SALE OR LEASE OF
THE PROPERTIES WHICH THE DECIES
ARE HOUSE JOHN --
BUT THE AMOUNT OF REVENUES WILL
BE HIGHLY --
DEPENDENT ON THE INDIVIDUAL
CHARACTERISTICS OF EACH OF THOSE
PROPERTIES AS WELL AS DECISIONS
THAT ARE MADE BY THE VARIOUS.
A GOVERNMENTAL STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ON PAGE NINE I I WON'T GO INTO
ALL OF THESE SINCE I'M DIRECTOR
BURGE MEN DID ADDRESS A NUMBER
OF THESE --
THESE ITEMS BUT WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE MAJOR
BUDGET ACTIONS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS --
FIRST TO FOCUS ON SOME OF THE
BUDGET SOLUTIONS --
THAT WERE MADE DURING THE RECENT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS.
AND THERE WAS A NAMELY A
REDUCTION IN BENEFITS IN TERMS
OF TIGHTENING THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA IN THE EARLY START
PROGRAM AND THIS WAS IN ORDER TO
REDUCE CASELOAD.
GROWTH --
AND THAT'S REDUCE COST THAT
ELIGIBILITY WAS RESTORED --
IN BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN SOCIAL A
RECREATION CAMP SERVICES WERE
SUSPENDED AND HAVE NOT YET BEEN
RESTORED --
EN RESPITE THE AMOUNT OF RESPITE
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL COULD RECEIVE
WAS LIMITED --
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET DID RESTORE THE FULL
AMOUNT OF A RESPITE TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL.
AND THERE WERE ALSO WHAT WERE
CALLING RESTRICTIONS TO VENDOR
RATES THE MOST IMPORTANT OF
THESE WERE RATE FREEZES SOME OF
WHICH STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE FOUR AND AFFECTING SOME
VENDORS AND THEN OTHERS IN --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE THESE
FREEZES STILL REMAIN IN PLACE
DESPITE THE STATE PROVIDING
FUNDING TO COVER THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH STATE MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES --
AND OF THE THE RATE INCREASES
THAT OCCURRED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN I WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
MEDIAN RATES HAS ALSO RESTRICTED
THE AMOUNT THAT VENDORS RECEIVE
SO THE MEDIAN RATES ARE
ESSENTIALLY --
THE RATES THAT A NEW VENDOR
COMING INTO THE SYSTEM WOULD
RECEIVE RATHER THAN BEING ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE THEIR RATE BASED ON
IT ON COST.
THEY HAVE TO ACCEPT THE CURRENT
STATEWIDE MEDIAN RATE FOR THAT
SERVICE OR THE REGIONAL CENTER
AREA RATE FOR THAT SERVICE
WHICHEVER OF THE TWO IS LOWER.
THAT MEDIAN RATE POLICY REMAINS
IN PLACE.
ON PAGE TEN WE MENTION --
SEVERAL OTHER SORT OF BUDGET
SOLUTIONS THAT ABOUT THAT
OCCURRED DURING THE RECENT
RECESSION --
SOME OF WHICH HAVE BEEN RESTORED
LIKE PAYMENT REDUCTIONS.
THE UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE WAS
ONE THAT TOOK EFFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND TO ESSENTIALLY --
BUT DESPITE IT BEING CALLED THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY POLICY WOULD
ESSENTIALLY MEANT WAS THAT
REGIONAL CENTERS WERE PROHIBITED
FROM PAYING.
FIRST A VENDORS FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED ON FOURTEEN SET DAYS
PER YEAR.
THIS WAS AN ISSUE THAT CAME UP
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD PROPOSED
BEGINNING TO RIP TO ENFORCE THIS
POLICY AGAIN IT'S BEEN SUSPENDED
SINCE.
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
HAD VOTED TO REPEAL THE POLICY
ALL TOGETHER THE COMPROMISE THAT
WAS REACHED WAS TO DELAY
ENFORCEMENT OF THE POLICY FOR
ONE MORE YEAR.
SOME OF THE RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS --
WE DON'T NEED TO GO INTO TOO
MUCH DEPTH ON NEEDS BUT YOU'LL
NOTE AND AND PAGE.
ELEVEN THE MAJOR ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN DURING THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN SPECIAL SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE SOME OF THESE
INVOLVED.
RE INCREASES FOR VENDORS A AND I
AND INCREASES TO REGIONAL CENTER
OPERATIONS THERE ALSO SOME FIXED
ALLOCATIONS PROVIDED FOR SOME
SPECIFIC PURPOSES SUCH AS
AMELIORATING THE DISPARITIES IN
PURCHASE OF SERVICE SPENDING
ACROSS RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS --
AMONG A D. S. CONSUMERS.
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
RESTORED RESPITE --
AND PROVIDED ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR SAFETY NET DEVELOPMENT THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
PROVIDED. TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
WHAT'S CALLED BRIDGE FUNDING AND
THIS IS FOR VENDORS WHO ARE BE
BEING PARTICULIER PARTICULARLY
HARD HIT BY RISING COSTS AND
IT'S MEANT TO BRIDGE THE THE
TIME BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE RATE
STUDY CAN BE POTENTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED --
ON PAGES TWELVE THROUGH --
FOURTEEN WE WANTED TO NOTE SOME
OF THE LOOKING AHEAD AND I WON'T
DWELL TOO LONG --
IN THIS SECTION BECAUSE DIRECTOR
BRIDGMAN DID ALREADY DISCUSSED
SOME OF THESE AND I KNOW SOME OF
THE PANELISTS COMING FOR REMOVAL
WILL TALK ABOUT THESE BUT WE
JUST WANTED TO NOTE TWO FACTORS
THAT ARE CAUSING SHIFTS IN THE
DTS SYSTEM. ONE AS THE SHIFTING
DEMOGRAPHICS WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSED AGAIN BUT WE WOULD
JUST NOTE FROM A FISCAL
PERSPECTIVE EACH OF THESE SHIPS
COMES WITH.
SORT OF FISCAL PRESSURE SO FOR
EXAMPLE OF THE RISE IN THE
NUMBER OF CONSUMERS WITH AUTISM
AND DUAL MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS.
MEANS IT'S MORE EXPENSIVE TO
SERVE THESE CONSUMERS THEN MAYBE
A OF MORE AVERAGE CONSUMER FROM
THE PAST.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
EVOLVING MODES OF SERVICE
DELIVERY AS THE DIRECTOR ALREADY
DISCUSSED A PAGE THIRTEEN NOTES
A FEW OF THESE DE
INSTITUTIONALIZATION AND MOVING
TO A A SYSTEM THAT'S ALMOST A
100% COMMUNITY BASED.
THE NEW FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT THE STATEMENTS COMPLY WITH
IN ORDER TO CONSTRUCTING TEN
YEAR RECEIVING FEDERAL FUNDING
WHICH REALLY TRIES TO INCREASE
INTEGRATION OF CONSUMERS AND TO
THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE NEW SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM THAT IS BEING ROLLED OUT.
I WE WOULD NOTE AS HAS ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED THERE'S THE
UPCOMING RATE STUDY. ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR THE STUDY IS THAT
THE RATES STRUCTURE IN THE DTS
SYSTEM.
IS VERY COMPLEX IT'S EVEN
COMPLEX ON PAPER JUST HOW --
AND RATES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SET
THERE'S ANY NUMBER OF WAYS THAT
RATES CAN BE SET THERE'S MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SERVICE
CODES.
BUT THIS STRUCTURE HAS BEEN MADE
EVEN MORE COMPLICATED BY THE
BUDGET SOLUTIONS AND SUBSEQUENT
ATTEMPTS TO AUGMENT AND RESTORE
THE DDS BUDGET SINCE THAT TIME.
I IT'S MADE --
FOR RATE STRUCTURE THAT IS IN.
THAT'S IN EQUITABLE ACROSS
VENDORS PROVIDING THE SAME
SERVICES.
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE IN THE SENSE
THAT --
NUMBER OF VENDORS ARE STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY AND IT PROVIDES A
DISINCENTIVE TO NEW VENDORS
COMING INTO THE SYSTEM --
AND IT'S AND IT'S QUITE RIGID SO
THE REASON FOR THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED FUNDING FOR THIS RATE
STUDY WAS REALLY TO ASSESS THE
STRUCTURE --
AND A EVALUATE DIFFERENT
METHODOLOGIES FOR SETTING RATES
AND THEN HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
GOOD ACTIONABLE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR SIMPLIFYING THE STRUCTURE --
FINALLY ON PAGE FOURTEEN WE
WOULD JUST NOTE --
A COUPLE OTHER ISSUES FACING THE
SYSTEM --
ONE IS THIS NOTION OF DEVELOPING
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY.
I HOUSING HAS ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED AS AS A PROBLEM BUT
THERE THE REGIONAL CENTERS AND
VENDORS HAVE REALLY BEEN
RESTRICTED FROM STARTING UP NEW
PROGRAMS IN RECENT YEARS DUE TO
FUNDING CHALLENGES --
AND IN SEVENTEEN THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR PROVIDED --
DDS WITH THE AUTHORITY TO USE
THE THE PART OF FUNDING THAT
THEY GET TO DEVELOP RESOURCES IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR PEOPLE MOVING
FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
IT CAN NOW BE EXPANDED TO
DEVELOP RESOURCES IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR THE ENTIRE DTS
SYSTEM -- SO
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
FUNDING IN AND A WAY FOR VENDORS
AND REGIONAL CENTERS TO DEVELOP
NEEDED.
PROGRAMS AND AND POTENTIALLY
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS.
AND THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE OF
RETAINING SERVICE PROVIDERS IN
THE SYSTEM PARTICULARLY.
AS THEY FACE.
MOSTLY FLAT RATES OVER THE PAST
NUMBER OF YEARS AS WELL AS
RISING COSTS THAT ARE OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL SUCH AS LOCAL
MINIMUM WAGES --
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY ALSO MAKES IT
HARD TO GET NEW VENDORS INTO THE
SYSTEM.
AND THEN FINALLY WE YOU KNOW
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE TO CONTINUE
PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION TO THE
NEED FOR SAFETY NET SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF YOUR TIME
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS THE PANEL OF OUR
EXPERTS FROM ILLEGAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING AN
EXTREMELY COMPLEX --
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
COMPLEX MORE UNDERSTANDABLE JUST
THE WAY IT'S LAID OUT --
I WAS JUST WONDERING REALLY
QUICKLY AND MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME
TILL YOUR PRESENTATION.
MAYBE MS ARGUMENT COULD HAVE
ANSWERED IF I HAD KNOWN BUT THE
REGIONAL ARE THE ARE BEING.
LEFT OPEN AND TRYING TO FIND THE
MONTH OVERLOAD --
SIX SIX THE ONES THAT ARE OPEN
ON A LIMITED BASIS.
ARE THEY LOOKED THE PORTERVILLE
IN THE CANYON SPRINGS OF THOSE
OUTPATIENTS OR THE FULL TIME SO
PORTER AT THIS SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM AT PORTERVILLE IS REALLY
DESIGNED FOR CONSUMERS WHO ARE
UNDER A COURT ORDER.
THEY'VE EITHER BEEN DECLARED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL --
OR HAVE BEEN --
PLACED IN THERE UNDER ANOTHER
TYPE OF COURT ORDER.
IDEALLY THEY WILL NOT LIVE THERE
FOR EVER AND THE DEPARTMENT IS
IN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING --
SERVICES AND HOMES TO SORT OF
STE THAT PEOPLE DOWN FROM THAT
FACILITY AND THEN ULTIMATELY GET
THEM PLACED IN THE COMMUNITY.
SEEM SIMILARLY CANYON SPRINGS IS
NOT MEANT TO BE --
LONG TERM --
RESIDENTIAL SOLUTION IT'S MEANT
TO BE MORE OF A TRANSITION AND
SORT OF TRAINING --
GROUND FOR THE CONSUMERS WHO
LIVE THERE --
AT MOST BETWEEN THE TWO
FACILITIES THEY CONSERVE ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY I'M DDS
CONSUMERS AND THERE'S NO PLAN AT
THIS POINT TO CLOSE EITHER OF
THOSE.
ESPECIALLY THE SECURE TREATMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS DOES PROVIDE A
A SORT OF NEEDED.
PLEASE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE MAYBE
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
[inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
WHERE'S THE CANYON SPRINGS
LOCATION IT'S DOWN IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
IN KITTY CATHEDRAL CITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR DIAGNOSIS SO THE SYSTEM CUT
HER.
I REALLY TO APPRECIATE --
YOUR CANDOR WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP LEóN AND THE
UNBIASED APPROACH THAT YOU TAKE.
AND GIVING US INFORMATION THAT
WE DESPERATELY NEED IN AND A
DISSEMINATING HOW WE CAN BE MORE
HELPFUL SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
YES AND EMPLOYEES NEVER HESITATE
IN THE FUTURE WHAT IF THE
COMMITTEE HAS QUESTIONS THAT WE
CAN HELP WITH ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. TO REMOVE ON TOUR A
THIRD PANEL --
AND THAT'S US UNDER SMITH FROM
WHICH IS THE CHAIR OF THE STATE
COUNCIL DEVELOPMENTAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
GOOD MORNING THINKING OR HAVING
ME.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID I AM
SANDERS MET AND I'M CHAIR OF THE
STATE COUNCIL FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND I'M HERE TO
GIVE YOU SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION YOU'VE JUST HEARD.
BUT IT BEARS BEING REPEATED I'D
AGREE I AM A PARENT OF A THIRTY
SIX YEAR OLD NONVERBAL.
AUTISTIC YOUNG MAN WHO IS JUST
RECENTLY BEEN PUT INTO A
POSITION WHERE HE CAN BE
INDEPENDENT LIVING WITH
ASSISTANCE FROM REGIONAL CENTERS.
IT TOOK ME TWO YEARS TO GET
THERE AND I HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
EDUCATION SO THIS IS A A TRIP A
JOURNEY THAT I'M CONTINUING AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUE WITH
MY SON TILT LIKES.
THE DEMOGRAPHICS FOR CALIFORNIA
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES
AND THIS IS JUST AN OVER THERE.
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS AGO CONGRESS
ESTABLISHED THE STATE COUNCIL ON
EVERY STATE AND TERRITORY
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ASSISTANCE AND BILL OF RIGHTS.
TWO THOUSAND AUTHORIZE COUNSEL
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE WITH MY DD
AND THEIR FAMILIES DESIGNED IT
ACCESS SERVICES TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
AND SUPPORTS.
THE LATTER MEANT ACTS THAT WISH
THAT STATE COUNCILS AND
CALIFORNIA'S DOUBLE EDGED OVER
THIRTY ONE MEMBERS APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS WITH ID DE
THEIR FAMILIES OTHER PARTNERS
AND STATE AGENCIES THE STATE
COUNT ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES A FIVE YEAR STATE
PLAN WHICH I WAS THE CHAIR UP.
IS IN THE PROCESS OF
IMPLEMENTING THE DD ACT THROUGH
THE WORK OF ITS TWELVE REGIONAL
OFFICES WE SPENT OUR OFFICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE UNLIKE MOST
THE COUNCIL'S.
THE PLAN IS DEVELOPED IN
STAKEHOLDERS AND PUT ADDRESS
SYSTEMATIC BARRIERS EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING EDUCATION COMMUNITIES
PORTS HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR
PERSONS WITH ID DE.
WHAT IS THE MISSION THE VISION
OF THE STATE COUNCIL OUR MISSION
OF THE CITY COUNCIL PROMOTES
[inaudible]
COUNSEL ADVOCATES PERMITS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE POLICIES
AND PRACTICES THAT ACHIEVE SELF
DETERMINATION INDEPENDENCE
PRODUCTIVITY INCLUSION AND ALL
ASPECTS OF THE COMMUNITY LIFE
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
OUR VISION FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES ARE
GUARANTEED THE SAME FULL AND
EQUAL OPPORTUNITIES LIFE LIBERTY
AND PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS IS ALL
AMERICANS.
WHAT AYE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT THE
CALIFORNIA POPULATION IT'S THE
FULL POPULATION OF?
OVER FORTY MILLION OR SO BUT SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND THEM ARE
REPRESENTED FROM ITT POPULATIONS
AS YOU CAN SEE ON THE NEXT GRAPH
CHART.
IT SHOWS THAT --
AND PEOPLE WITH SERVED WITH THE
REGIONAL CENTERS IS THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND US
OBJECTIVE PARCHMENT.
WE BEAT IT AND OF THOSE IN THE
STATE THERE IT'S ALMOST SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND THAT
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS.
WHAT IS THE STATE OF EDUCATION
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH IT DE? TO
SEIZE SPECIAL EDUCATION OR
RELATED SERVICES UNDER THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT A STUDENT WITH A
DISABILITY MASS.
BE ELIGIBLE UNDER ONE OF
THIRTEEN SPECIFIC CATEGORIES AND
IN NEED OF SERVICES THERE IS NO
SPECIFIC CATEGORY FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE IN CALIFORNIA THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF STUDENTS AGES SIX TO
TWENTY ONE SERVED UNDER IDA IS
600-660-00400 FOURTEEN
APPROXIMATELY 230-004-0050.
NINE OR THREATENED THREE POINT
5% OF THE STUDENTS IN THIS
CATEGORY WOULD CONSIDER CONSIDER
STUDENTS WITH AN INTELLECTUAL A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
WHAT IS THE EMPLOYMENT STATE?
FOR CALIFORNIA AS YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE GRAPH ON ON THE BOARD
THEIR FORMER TEACHER HERE.
IT SHOWS POPULATION HAVE.
WHAT WE HAVE THERE'S 80%?
AND THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
[inaudible]
35% AND THOSE RECEIVING SERVICES
AT PULSE 25%. FOR SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR THAT SIMILAR NUMBERS
BUT MUCH LOWER.
AND THE SIX THE SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED.
SO WHAT IS THE STATE OF HOUSING
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH IT DE.
THAT'S MANY NUMBERS WERE
INDIVIDUALS BY LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS ARE SO SUPERVISE
HOUSING AS YOU CAN SEE IS THAT
THE GREEN AREA HIGHLIGHTED.
AND ALONE OR WITH THE ROOMMATE
WHERE MY SON IS NOW HE HAS A
ROOMMATE HE CANNOT EVER LIVE
ALONE IT'S 16%.
AND FORTUNATELY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MOST THE POPULATION
CONTINUES TO LIVE WITH THEIR
FAMILIES BUT NOT NECESSARILY BY
DESIRING THAT.
THE INDIVIDUALS MY SON LIKE I
SAID IT TOOK TWO YEARS TO GET
THEM IN A PLACEMENT THAT WOULD
WORK FOR HIM.
DOES ANYONE IS LIVE AT HOME I
CAN FIND A VENDOR TO DO SO SO
THAT IS A BIG BECAUSE BECAUSE OF
HOUSING COSTS.
WHAT IS THE STATE HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIA FADED THE PERSON
SERVED BY?
THE SETTING FOR TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN PEOPLE WITH ID DE LIVING
IN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS WAS OVER ELEVEN
THOUSAND SUPPORTED LIVING WITH.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OTHER SMALL
RESIDENTS DID READ JUST DENTAL
EXCUSE ME GROUPS TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND A LITTLE BIT OVER THAT.
SO IN THE STATE OF HOUSING FOR
CALIFORNIANS THE END TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE AVERAGE AND
ANNUAL INCOME OF ITS SINGLE
PERSON RECEIVING SSI WAS.
NINE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX ABOUT 22% BELOW THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
AN EQUAL TO ONLY 20% OF THE
NATIONAL MEDIAN INCOME FOR A ONE
PERSON HOUSE [inaudible]
THAT'S JUST.
NOT SOMETHING WE CAN LIVE ON IT
WON'T WORK.
IN CALIFORNIA 500-924-0060 SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE RECEIVE SSI THE
AVERAGE SSI PAYMENT IS EIGHT
HUNDRED GLOBAL NINE DOLLARS THE
PERCENTAGE OF S. SITE SS I NEED
IT FOR A ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT
IS ABOUT A 138%.
OF THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT AND 117%
FOR AN OFFICIAL C. APARTMENT
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT INDIVIDUAL
HAVE TO BE ALONE AND RECEIVE
SERVICES COMING INTO THE HOME TO
HELP THEM OUT.
SO WHAT ARE THE DISPARITIES IN
THE PROCESS OF SERVICES AS YOU
CAN SEE ON THE CHART IT'S LISTED
BY ETHNICITY SO AMERICAN ON THE
AND THROUGH A ASIAN.
AFRICAN AMERICAN BLACKS HISPANIC
NATIVE HAWAIIAN OR OTHER OTHER
ETHNICITIES IN MULTI CULTURAL.
SO THE PERCENTAGE OF AFTER OF
AMERICAN INDIAN RECEIVING IT
SERVICES IS THAT POINT 3%.
THERE WAS AN ASIAN IS EIGHT
POINT 9%.
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR BLACK EIGHT
POINT 6%.
SPANNING THIRTY NINE POINT 5%.
NATIVE HAWAIIAN OR OTHER PACIFIC
ISLAND POINT 2%.
OTHER ESTIMATES ETHNICITIES OR
MULTICULTURAL LEVIN POINT 2% AND
WIDER CAUCASIAN THIRTY ONE POINT
3%.
THAT IS MY PRESENT AGE FOR THE
DAY ON THE COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE.
A GROUP OF PARENTS AND PARTNERS
AS I SAID BEFORE WE ALL HAVE
PASSION AS YOU DO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME.
AND ENERGY ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
ARE HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE BEEN MY STEP PERCENT
SINCE BE ABLE HELPED.
MISTER MONNING QUESTIONS OF THE
POST.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
PULLED HIM [inaudible]
JUST.
YOU HAVE A KNOWLEDGE OF THIS
ENTIRE SYSTEM WHAT.
COULD WE BE DOING BETTER WHAT DO
WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING OUR
ENERGY ON THERE'S LOTS OF
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS WE GET.
CHANNEL THAT ENERGY WHERE DO YOU
SEE [inaudible]
THE LARGEST EFFICIENCY AND THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF HOW WE
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR ME PERSONALLY AS
I WAS SAYING I STRUGGLE WITH
GETTING VENDORS TO SERVE AND
PROVIDE FOR MY SON --
STILL HOUSING HAVE TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT SO ALL OF THESE
FACTORS EMPLOYMENT THE IF YOU'RE
NOT MAKING ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY
RENT.
BUT YOU CAN'T GET EMPLOYED
BECAUSE HAVE ISSUES OF HOW MUCH
MONEY YOU CAN RECEIVE THEN IT'S
LIKE A VICIOUS CIRCLE.
AND THERE'S LIKE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A BOMB.
LOCATION WHERE EVERYBODY CAN GO
AND SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
BECAUSE YOU NEED THEM.
NOT BECAUSE IT FELT A LOT OF
PAPERWORK I CAN GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE JUST HAPPENED TO ME
RECENTLY BECAUSE OF A MIX UP MY
SON SERVICES MEDIC CAO AND IN
HOME SUPPORT.
WE JUST CANCEL.
I DID GET A PHONE CALL I GOT A
LETTER RESPONDED TO THE LETTER
BUT NEEDLESS TO SAY I SIT HERE
IS THE CHAIR OF THE STATE
COUNCIL DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES
BUT I WON A WEEK.
AND PARENTING JUST RECENTLY NOT
KNOWING WHAT I DO IF SOMETHING
HAPPENED TO MY SON TOGETHER
SEIZURE SOMETHING NO MEDICATION
SO IT'S A IT'S A COMBINATION OF
ALL THESE FACTORS.
BUT FOCUSING ON THE INDIVIDUAL
HAS TO BE PERSON CENTER AND S.
B. LED BY WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS LIKE I SAID MY SON THIRTY
SIX FINALLY LIVING ON ITS OWN.
HIDDEN WANNA LIVE AT HOME.
ALL THESE YEARS BUT THERE WAS NO
OTHER OPTION FOR ME.
SO GIVING OPTIONS THE BIGGEST
THING INTO AND PULLING OUR
DOLLARS IN THE DIRECTION OF
FAMILIES THAT SERVE THEIR
INDIVIDUALS AT HOME MAKING SURE
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF TWO THE
FACT THAT THERE AT
INDIVIDUALISTS AT HOME DOES NOT
MEAN THEY DON'T NEED THE SAME
SERVICES.
THAT IS ONE OF THE CONCERNS I
HAVE AS WELL.
AND MY STAFF PERSON MIGHT BE
ABLE TO BE SMART DOCUMENT.
NUMBERS AND STATS.
NO IT'S A SIMILAR TO WHAT CENTER
SAID WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT
WHAT ACTIVITIES THE COUNCIL'S
GOING TAKE UNDER THIS PAST YEAR
IN TERMS OF OUR POLICY WORK.
THEORIES WE CONSISTENTLY HEARD
FROM ACROSS THE STATE WHERE WE
NEED TO WORK ON THE PLAN SYSTEM
AND MAKE SURE THAT INDIVIDUALS
CAN GET JOBS AND RETAIN THOSE
JOBS.
AND WE ALSO NEED TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS RENT OFFICIALS
APARTMENT DISABILITIES IN THE
STATE.
THOSE THE TWO ISSUES THAT
CONSISTENT CAME UP WITH EVERYONE
I TALK.
TO THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
THANK FATTEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY FOR YOUR SON AND HANG
IN THERE RIGHT NOW YEARS IS A
LONG TIME BUT YEAH.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NICE TO KNOW
THAT --
CONTINENTS PROBLEM TERM AND I'VE
HEARD FROM FAMILIES THIRD.
THEIR SON OR DAUGHTER AND WHOSE
AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM IT
TWENTY TWO AND LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES --
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE
LEGISLATION TO OF CREATE THE
WORKFORCE IMMIGRATION HOW WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO OF LOOKING
FORWARD TO A ALSO WORKING
TOWARDS THE THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
MANDATE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS A PROCESS IN
PLACE GOING FORWARD.
HON THAT BEING SAID --
YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA.
LEAN ON YOU VERY HEAVILY BECAUSE
YOU ARE AGAIN EXPERTS IN YOUR
FIELD ABOUT --
HOW WE CAN BETTER ADVOCATING ITS
THIS?
SO MEMORABLE MOMENTS IS SAYING
WERE OPEN AND WILLING TO YOU
KNOW TO BE THERE IS HERE THE
EXPERTS AND AND YOU HAVE TO
GUIDE US WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
AND JUST MY MUCH OF THE LAST FEW
YEARS I DOESN'T DOESN'T ENTER.
TWENTY ONE AND THAT'S A WHOLE
NOTHER ISSUE BUT I HAD TO PUT IT
OUT THAT SUMMARY.
KNOWN ACTUALLY EATEN AGAIN
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU KNOW LIFE
SKILLS SINCE THE TWENTY ONE OR
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD.
WE'VE GOT A LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FROM THAT
POINT FOR NOW BECAUSE YOU KNOW
AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM THAT THE
FALLING OFF THAT CLIFF IS NOT
APPROPRIATE YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY
WHEN AND VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY WELL FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU POLICY.
THINKING.
WE MOVE ON TO OUR UP --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION REGIONAL CENTERS AMY
WESTLING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONVENING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING.
AND FOR BEGINNING AN IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE ABOUT HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD NOT JUST LOOKING AT A
SPECIFIC BILL BUT AS A SYSTEM TO
PRESERVE THE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THANK YOU ALSO TO YOUR STAFF.
FOR ALL OF THE WORK THAT WENT
INTO COORDINATING THIS HEARING.
BEFORE I MOVE ON I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO REFLECT ON SOMETHING
THAT DIRECTOR PARCHMAN SAID
[inaudible]
THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM FOR SERVING
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IS DIFFERENT
[inaudible]
THAT IT.
WAS AND AT ITS INCEPTION A MODEL
FOR THE NATION.
AND I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF WAYS THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM IS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE HAVE NO WEIGHTLESS
FOR ENTRY INTO THE SYSTEM.
IN VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER STATE
IN THE COUNTRY THERE ARE WAIT
LISTS [inaudible]
AND THEY CAN BE A DECADE OR MORE
LONG.
SO THE FACT THAT WE HAVE MADE A
COMMITMENT TO EVERY ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUAL IS A SIGNIFICANT
THING.
ADDITIONALLY IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE THERE WAS A
COURT DECISION THAT SOLIDIFIED
BUT NOT ONLY DO PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO ENTRY INTO THE SYSTEM
BUT THEY HAVE A RIGHT. TO NEEDED
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS THAT STEM
FROM THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
ANOTHER WAY THAT OUR SYSTEM IS
DIFFERENT IS THAT THERE IS
INTENTIONAL LOCAL CONTROL WHICH
IS INTENDED TO ALLOW.
AIR EACH AREA OF THE STATE TO
DRIVE SERVICE DELIVERY THAT
FEELS BEST THAT IS THE BEST
CULTURAL FIT FOR THEIR AREA.
BUT IT ALSO ENABLES REGIONAL
CENTERS TO BE MORE NIMBLE AND
AGILE THAN A STATE AGENCY.
WE RECOGNIZED EARLY ON IN
CALIFORNIA BUT NOT ONE SIZE FITS
ALL.
BUT RATHER.
WE IS A SYSTEM NEED TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT PEOPLE
ARE EXPERTS IN THEIR OWN LIVES.
AND THIS CONCEPT HAS COME TO THE
FORWARD.
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RECENTLY RECOGNIZING THAT WE
NEED.
TO PLANNED FOR INDIVIDUALS LIVES
WITH THEM.
IN A WAY THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
NOT ONLY WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT ALSO
THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT TO
THE PERSON.
THOSE THINGS THAT HELP THE
PERSON. TO WANT TO GET UP IN THE
MORNING AND TO WANT TO GREET THE
DAY.
WE KNOW THAT DEMOGRAPHICS PLAY A
HUGE ROLE IN SERVICE DELIVERY.
AS DIRECTOR BARGE MEN NOTED AS
WELL AS MISS PETTITTE FROM THE
LA SHOW.
OUR DEMOGRAPHICS IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE SHIFTED SIGNIFICANTLY.
AT THE INCEPTION OF OUR SYSTEM
FIFTY YEARS AGO.
OUR POPULATION WAS 75% WHITE AND
10% HISPANIC.
AND TODAY WE'RE A RICH TAPESTRY
OF VARIOUS ETHNICITIES AND
BACKGROUNDS WITH OVER FORTY
LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM.
WE KNOW THAT [inaudible]
CULTURAL VALUES.
DR DIFFERENT CHOICES.
WE KNOW THAT IN SOME CULTURES.
THE PREFERENCE IS FOR TO
MAINTAIN INDIVIDUALS AT HOME.
AND AS MS SMITH SAID WE KNOW
THAT.
IF THE CHOICE IS TO MAINTAIN
YOUR LOVED ONE AT HOME.
WE IS A SYSTEM HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO SUPPORT THAT INDIVIDUAL.
AND TO SUPPORT THAT FAMILY TO
WRAP OURSELVES AROUND THAT
FAMILY TO ENABLE THEM.
TO MEET THEIR REQUIREMENTS. TO
KEEP THEIR LOVED ONE AT HOME.
NO MATTER WHAT THE DEMOGRAPHICS.
THE ABSOLUTE GOAL MUST BE EQUAL
ACCESS TO SERVICES BETTER
VALUABLE AND THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUAL THAT OUR
PRICE FROM THEIR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
AS BOTH DIRECTOR BARGE MEN AND
MISS PATRICK NOTED.
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING.
TRY DIFFERENT THINGS TO SEA
WATER THOSE THINGS THAT ARE MOST
RESPONSIVE TO DIFFERENT CULTURES.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
NEED TO AS A STATE MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO FUND WHATEVER
WORKS.
AND TO MAKE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO FUNDING THOSE
THING.
AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT PROGRESS IN THIS AREA TAKES
[inaudible]
TIME.
THAT THERE ARE BARRIERS THERE
ARE ISSUES RELATED TO SERVICE
DELIVERY SOME OF WHICH HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH.
THE REGIONAL CENTER OR THEIR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE INDIVIDUAL.
SO IT MAY BE THAT IN SOME
POPULATIONS.
THERE ARE ISSUES AROUND OF
MISTRUST OF GOVERNMENT AND THE
BELIEF THAT REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
GOVERNMENT.
PARTICULARLY IN THIS ECONOMIC
I'M SORRY IN THIS POLITICAL
CULTURE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
NEED TO MEET PEOPLE'S NEEDS AND
WE NEED TO MEET THEM WHERE THERE
OUT RATHER THAN TRY TO PUT THEM
INTO A BOX.
DIRECTOR BARGE MEN NOTED THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM WAS
INITIALLY DEVELOPED.
AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INSTITUTIONAL CARE.
IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WE HAD
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND STATE RUN
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND AS WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY
THAT POPULATION IS DOWN TO UNDER.
FIVE HUNDRED AND IMPORTANT
TURNING POINT IN THE
DEPOPULATION OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS WAS THAT WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE CAR FELT DECISION
IN THE EARLY NINETIES.
WHICH LED TO THE STATE
COMMITTING TO NOT ONLY THE
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE OUT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS.
BUT ALSO THE APPROPRIATE
DEVELOPMENT OF ALTERNATIVE
SERVICES. FOR INSTANCE
SUPPORTIVE LIVING SERVICES
FAMILY HOME AGENCIES WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL MOVES INTO.
THE HOME OF ANOTHER FAMILY WHO
SUPPORTS NOT ALONE WHO SUPPORTS
NO MORE THAN TWO INDIVIDUALS.
HOMES FOR MEDICALLY FRAGILE
CHILDREN [inaudible]
SUPPLEMENTAL STAFFING TO ENABLE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO OFFER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN [inaudible]
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS.
AS WELL AS THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE COMMUNITY PLACEMENT PLAN
WHICH IS PROVIDED A FUNDING
STRUCTURE TO ENABLE.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEEDED
RESOURCES SINCE THAT TIME.
WHILE THE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE OUT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IS
IMPRESSIVE IN THE AGGREGATE WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT IT'S DONE
ONE SINGLE PERSON AT A TIME.
THE ABSOLUTE GOAL [inaudible]
IS.
TO INSURER BUT EACH PERSON HAS
EVERYTHING THEY NEED THEIR FIRST
DAY IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND THAT THAT MOVEMENT
[inaudible]
ISN'T JUST.
MOVING THEM FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER BUT IT'S USED AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE THEIR
LIVES THAT IS THE GOAL IT'S NOT
THE SHUDDERING OF STATE.
RUN FACILITIES IT IS THE
ENHANCING OF INDIVIDUAL LIVES.
IN TERMS OF HOUSING.
OUR POPULATION IS A LITTLE BIT
UNIQUE.
WE DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC SET
ASIDES FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THERE'S NO SPECIAL
FUNDING STREAM AT THIS TIME.
IN PART BECAUSE MOST OF OUR
POPULATION DOESN'T KNOW ONE
SHELTERED.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL APPROACHES A
REGIONAL CENTER AND REQUESTS
[inaudible]
SHELTER.
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM
TO MOVE INTO SETTINGS.
BUT WE KNOW [inaudible]
THAT.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT EXPECTATIONS
AND DIFFERENT INTERESTS IN TERMS
OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR
TODAY.
IT MAYBE THAT LESS PEOPLE ARE
SEEKING GROUP LIVING AND MORE
ARE SEEKING INDEPENDENT LIVING.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REALLY SUPPORTS THIS.
IF WE THINK BACK TO JUST FIFTY
YEARS AGO.
THE IDEA OF COMMUNITY THE IDEA
OF PROVIDING ANY OF THE SERVICES
OUTSIDE OF A DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER WAS NOVEL AND YOU NEED.
AND WE HAVE EVOLVED SO THAT NOW
WE EXPECT AND THE PEOPLE WE
SUPPORT EXPECT TO BE FULLY
INCLUDED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THAT MEANS.
REGULAR HOUSING FOR MANY OF THEM.
CALIFORNIA HAS.
THE HIGHEST POVERTY RATE IN THE
NATION WHEN.
KIT COST OF LIVING IS TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT.
HIGHEST INTERESTINGLY EN LA
COUNTY IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
REGIONAL COST DIFFERENCES MAKE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN NOTED
EARLIER.
ANY NO COUNTY IN THE STATE IS
HOUSING AFFORDABLE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO RENT EVEN A STUDIO
APARTMENT.
WHO RELIES ON SSI?
DIRECTOR PARCHMENT EARLIER NOTED
THAT. ONE OF THE KEY PROMISES
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE LONG PROMISED PEOPLE.
IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO LIVE IN A
COMMUNITY OF THEIR CHOOSING.
BUT HOW DO WE DO THAT.
IF WE DON'T HAVE A DEDICATED
POOL OF DOLLARS TO ADDRESS THE
REAL HOUSING NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY MISS MATH FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL NOTED THAT.
JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE LIVES AT
HOME DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S ALWAYS
THEIR CHOICE SO WE REALLY HAVE
TO DRILL DOWN AND FIGURE OUT.
WHO IS NEEDING HOUSING AND FOR
WHOM [inaudible]
IS THE ON AFFORDABILITY OF
HOUSING.
IN THEIR WAY IN TERMS OF THEM
ACHIEVING THEIR GOALS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THOSE SERVICES
DESIGNED TO IMPROVE HOUSING
ACCESS FOR THE GENERAL
POPULATION ARE OVERTAXED.
IN MANY COUNTIES [inaudible]
HOUSING VOUCHERS THE WAITING
LIST FOR THOSE OPEN.
ONCE A DECADE.
AND THE INFLUX OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE INTERESTED IN THOSE
VOUCHERS.
IT'S SO SIGNIFICANT BUT THEY DO
A LOT OF REACH SOMETIMES JUST TO
GET ON THE WAITING LIST.
SO YOU MAY NOT AFTER WAITING A
DECADE EVEN GET ON THE WAITING
LIST FOR A HOUSING VOUCHER.
WE NEED A MORE DEDICATED
SOLUTION FOR OUR POPULATION.
IN TERMS OF THE SAFETY NET.
WE KNOW THAT.
AS MISS PETTITTE POINTED OUT.
BUT CERTAIN POPULATIONS BUT
MAKEUP ORDERED RICH DEMOGRAPHICS
TODAY ARE MORE EXPENSIVE TO
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY THOSE WITH
AUTISM AS WELL AS THOSE WHO HAVE
A GOOD AND ADDITIONAL
PSYCHIATRIC DIAGNOSES.
TODAY IN THE COMMUNITY BASED
SYSTEM OF 11% OF PEOPLE HAVE A
DUAL DIAGNOSIS [inaudible] 18%.
RECEIVE A BEHAVIORAL MEDICAID
MEDICATION OF SOME SORT 20% HAVE
A SPECIAL HEALTH REQUIREMENT.
AND 5% OUR TECHNOLOGY DEPENDENT.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE WHEN THERE
WAS A MORATORIUM PUT ON
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER PLACEMENTS
EXCEPT BRING VERY LIMITED
SITUATIONS.
THE DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS CAN NO
LONGER SERVICE THE BACKSTOP WHEN
SOMEONE IS STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN COMMUNITY PLACEMENT.
A LOT OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE. TO
DEVELOP COMMUNITY RESOURCES TO
MEET THESE NEEDS.
SPECIFICALLY A CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR CHANGES IN BEHAVIORAL
STABILITY.
RECOGNIZING THAT.
WHAT SOMEONE NEEDS? TO RIP TO
MAINTAIN THEIR BEHAVIORAL
STABILITY TODAY MAY LOOK
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT THEY REQUIRE
A YEAR FROM NOW.
AND THAT OUR SYSTEM HAS TO BE
FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO RESPOND TO
THOSE INCREASES AS WELL AS
DECREASES IN SUPPORT MEANS.
ALL OF THESE POPULATIONS REQUIRE
MORE REGIONAL CENTER STAFF TIME
FOR SERVICE COORDINATION
RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT MONITORING.
AND JUST BRIEFLY BEFORE A WRAP
UP I WANT TO JUST NOTE THAT
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT.
THE FUNDING CHALLENGES THAT THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM
HAS TODAY.
MISS PATRICK NOTED THAT OUR ROOM
CURRENT RATE STRUCTURE WITH ITS
MEDIAN RATES.
IS INEQUITABLE UNSUSTAINABLE AND
RIGID.
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHAT IMPACT
DOES THIS HAVE ON REAL PEOPLE ON
THOSE THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
SUPPORTED BY THE SYSTEM TODAY.
WE KNOW THAT THE DIRECT WORKS
THAT'S DONE WITH INDIVIDUALS IS
OFTEN PAID AT MINIMUM WAGE.
AND THAT THOSE JOBS ARE REALLY
COMPLEX ESPECIALLY AS WE EXPECT
THAT PEOPLE WILL HAVE GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACCESS THE ROOT
COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER NOTED A
COUPLE OF TIMES THE IMPORTANCE
OF CONSISTENCY IN STAFFING.
AND IF WE AS A SYSTEM CAN'T PAY
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE
CONSISTENCY IS INCREDIBLY HARD
TO MAINTAIN OR ACHIEVE.
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY A WAY TO NOT
ONLY PAY MORE ROBUST WAGES FOR
THESE POSITIONS.
BUT TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS A
CAREER TRACK.
BUT PEOPLE WILL STAY AND SEE
PROMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
[inaudible]
AND FIND.
A LIFE FULL OF PASSION AND
SUPPORTING THIS POPULATION.
THE RATE STUDY.
AS WE'VE HEARD IS --
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
ARE DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
MARCH OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE NEED
A COMMITMENT TO FUND WHATEVER
RECOMMENDATIONS COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
AS WAS NOTED EARLIER A STUDY ON
ITS OWN.
IS NICE.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A COMMITMENT.
TO TAKE THAT NEXT STEP
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
REGIONAL CENTER FUNDING.
FORMULA FOR FUNDING FORMULAS FOR
ITS STAFFING.
ARE ALSO VERY ANTIQUATED WITH
SOME OF THE FIXED COSTS WALKED
IN AT RATES THAT WERE SET IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE A POTENTIAL
SOURCE OF FUNDING AS MISS
PATRICK NOTED.
WOULD BE TO LOOK AT IS THERE A
WAY TO PULL IN SOME OF THE
FUNDING FROM THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS AS THE CLUB'S. TO FIND A
WAY TO KEEP THOSE RESOURCES IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND TO STABILIZE OUR SYSTEM NOT
ONLY FOR NOW BUT FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS [inaudible]
IN CLOSING.
WE'VE SEEN MANY CHANGES OVER THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS IN OUR SERVICE
SYSTEM.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY
[inaudible]
WE ALL.
THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION REGIONAL CENTERS
SPENDERS FAMILY IS INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE SUPPORTED.
HAVE A COMMITMENT TO MEETING
EACH INDIVIDUAL'S UNIQUE NEEDS.
BUT WE ONLY HAVE THE TOOLS TO DO
IT.
THANK YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THIS DRAWING OF A QUESTIONS OF
OUR PANELISTS [inaudible]
SO.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE --
STAFFING LEVELS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS UP AS A WHOLE Y. KNOW
EACH ONE HAS ITS OWN DYNAMIC --
IS THERE A GENERAL --
NUMBER THE YOU HAVE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY.
SO WHAT KIND OF STAFFING LEVELS
YOU EITHER DEFICIENT ARE IN AND
WHAT YOU WOULD NEED TO DO CUT
ICE I SEE THAT THE THE THE AREA
THAT SERVICE LEVEL ARE AREAS ARE
VERY LARGE.
AND SO WHAT WOULD.
TWENTY ONE CENTERS THROUGHOUT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES --
SO ZERO SERVICE LEVEL THAT
YOU'RE AT NOW THAT --
PICTURE YOU CAN STATE.
PROBABLY THE GREATEST INDICATOR
THE MOST VISIBLE ONE IS CASELOAD
RATIOS THERE'S A STATUTORY --
COMMITMENT TO CASELOAD RATIOS
THAT FOR SOME POPULATIONS IS ONE
TO SIXTY TWO ONE SERVICE
COORDINATOR FOR EVERY SIXTY TO
INDIVIDUAL SUPPORTED.
AND FOR OTHERS IS --
ONE TO SIXTY SIX DEPENDING ON
FEDERAL FUNDING STREAMS.
AND BUT FOR THOSE WHO HAVE MOVED
FROM DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS MOST
RECENTLY IT'S ONE TO FORTY FIVE
TODAY THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE IS
ABOUT -- ONE
TO SEVENTY FOUR WHICH IF YOU
LOOK AT THE JOB OF A SERVICE
COORDINATOR.
THE JOB HAS BECOME MORE COMPLEX
IN PART BECAUSE WE HAVE FEDERAL
DOLLARS FLOWING INTO THE SYSTEM
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
REQUIRES IN TENTS OF
DOCUMENTATION.
IT USED TO BE THAT SERVICE
COORDINATORS GOT TO SPEND A LOT
MORE TIME WITH PEOPLE IN THEIR
FAMILIES GETTING TO KNOW THEM
GETTING TO KNOW THEIR UNIQUE
DYNAMICS.
AND THE JOBS HAVE BECOME
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AT SINCE THAT
TIME.
AT THE SAME TIME THE CASELOAD
RATIOS HAVE RISEN.
I THINK AT LAST COUNT THE
SERVICE SYSTEM WAS ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SERVICE COORDINATOR
SHORT --
WHICH MAKES A DIFFERENCE
[inaudible]
IT IS.
THOSE ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE ON EACH CASE LOAD
REALLY DO PULL AWAY FROM THAT
TIME THAT COULD BE SPENT. TO DO
MORE THOUGHTFUL [inaudible]
PLANNING [inaudible]
AND TIME SPENT IN MORE PROACTIVE
ACTIVITY.
SEEING THAT YOU KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED OF SERVICE.
THE CUSTOMER SERVICES THEN.
BEEN --
ACUTELY --
COMPROMISED.
I'M ALWAYS IMPRESSED BY THE
RESILIENCY OF THE REGIONAL
CENTERS AND BY THE INCREDIBLE
COMMITMENT ON THE PART OF THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS.
BUT PEOPLE WOULD DO BETTER.
IF THEY HAD.
LOWER CASELOAD RATIOS.
THERE'S NO GETTING AROUND THE
FACT THAT IT WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME FOR PLANNING.
AND TALKING AND GETTING TO KNOW
ONE ANOTHER.
AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING
INDIVIDUAL PREFERENCES AS WELL
AS FINDING UNIQUE WAYS TO MAIM
EACH INDIVIDUAL'S NEEDS.
HAS THE REGIONAL CENTERS TRACKED
A RETENTION OF EMPLOYEES ONCE
HAVE BEEN HIGHER WAS AVERAGE
LENGTH OF TIME THAT THEY'LL THEY
THEY STAY.
HOME HIS YOU SAY THERE'S BEEN NO.
A PROBLEM WITH IT KEPING
EMPLOYEES.
YES I BELIEVE AS PART OF THE A.
B. X. TWO ONE THERE WAS A
REQUIREMENT TO TRACK NOT LONG
JAVADI NECESSARILY BUT TURNOVER
RATES I DON'T HAVE THAT WITH ME
TODAY BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO GET
THAT TO YOU.
APPRECIATE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE NUMBERS THAT
WE WOULD HELP US --
JUST BASED ON OF AS YOU TALK A
CAREER CHOICE --
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
ABILITY TO WANT TO WORK IN THIS
COMPLEX WORLD.
WHO ARE TRAINED TO WORK IN THIS
WORLD AND --
THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY
NEED [inaudible]
A THEY HAVE A SKILL SET THAT IS
VALUABLE TO THIS CONSUMER SO.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT SO THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS IT ALSO.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE --
AND AND APPRECIATE THE REGIONAL
CENTERS FOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND AND UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
LIMITED RESOURCES THAT WE GIVE
THEM I CAN ON MY COMMITMENT IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WORK
TOWARDS [inaudible]
OF A REVENUE SOURCE LIKE WE DID
WITH MESA --
SO YOU KNOW NOT NECESSARILY
ATTACKS BUT WE DID MAKE A
COMMITTED EFFORT FOR REVENUE
WITH THE MILLIONAIRES TAX AND
FOR THE MENTAL [inaudible]
SO.
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T ALWAYS COULD
CONTINUE.
TO ACCESS THE GENERAL FUND WITH
THE CYCLE THAT IT GOES THROUGH
IN ANY CONSISTENT FUNDING.
SO LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
EXPLORING ALL POTENTIAL SOURCES
OF FUNDING --
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO ENHANCE
THE SYSTEM IS GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
SO WE MOVE ON TO OUR EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS ID
DO YOU THAT'LL BE WILL SANFORD
HE'S THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
FUTURES EXPLORED.
SO MR SAN FOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
INTRODUCE --
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS ARE JOINING
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL SIT WITH
FUTURES EXPLORED WE SUPPORTS
BILLION INCLUSIVE COMMUNITIES
FOR OVER SEVEN OR INDIVIDUALS
ARE CROSSED TO REGIONAL CENTERS
AND EMPLOYMENTS A VERY IMPORTANT
THING IS MISS WESLEY POINTED OUT.
IT'S ABOUT CONTROL.
WHEN YOU'RE EMPLOYED YOU HAVE
DOLLARS YOU CAN SPEND AND YOU
CAN DO IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN
SUPPORT EMPLOYMENT STARTED?
MANY THINGS CAME AFTER THAT
SUPPORTED LIVING KILL BIN TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY ON THEIR OWN
AND DO THINGS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MONEY AND THEY COULD WORK.
THE PEOPLE SAID HEY THAT'S A
REALLY COOL THING SO.
ABOUT THE BOOKS WITH ME --
WITH THE DIVE IS MY REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE SACRAMENTO AREA
WHO WORKS EXTENSIVELY IN
EMPLOYMENT HAS WORKED ON A
COUPLE OF PROJECTS THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS HAS PUT
INTO PLACE THAT YOU CAN DESCRIBE
THOSE.
ALONG WITH THE TWO FOLKS ARE
EMPLOYED IN ONE DIRECTION
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL.
BECAUSE ONE THE CHALLENGES ABOUT
TALKING AND EMPLOYMENT IS
[inaudible]
JOB TESTIFY IN FRONT OF YOU
BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET PAID SO.
IT'S KIND OF THIS THING AND WE
HAVE AND THE YOUNG WOMAN WHO WAS
RECENTLY EMPLOYED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
AND SHE WAS WORRIED ABOUT.
HAVING COME HERE AND ASK FOR
TIME OFF UNDER SECOND WEEK ON
THE JOB AND WE RESPECTED THAT
CHOICE.
I OFFERED JUST TO TALK TO THE
DIRECTOR SAY WHAT HE LETTER COME
ACROSS THE STREET AND TALKIN SHE
SAID NO I'M GOOD I'LL I'LL I'LL
WORK AND SO --
WE HAVE ONE OF OUR DRUG SERVICE
PROVIDERS CAN REPORT THAT THE
LENSES CAN INTRODUCE.
OUR NEXT UPS.
I'M I THINK SO THIS IS TONY
VICKERS HE IS A WHAT ALL LET HIM
TALK ABOUT.
HELLO MY NAME IS TONY VICKERS --
THROUGH MY LOCAL REGIONAL CENTER
I WAS INTRODUCED TO FUTURE
EXPLORED SPECIFICALLY VERA
PHILOMENA WORKSHOP PROGRAM.
ORDER COURSES SEVERAL SEMESTERS
OF TITANIC THERE I GAINED A LOT
OF HARD AND SOFT SKILLS IN AND
LIVE IN VARIOUS --
DEPARTMENTS IN.
THE FIELD.
I TOOK A SPECIAL INTEREST IN
POST PRODUCTION.
AND THANKS TO SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES SAID THE WORK AT
THE WORKSHOP IN FUTURES AS
PROVIDE FOR ME I WAS ABLE --
TO I WAS ABLE TO LIKE GET A LOT
OF BOB HANDS ON EXPERIENCES BOTH
IN HOUSE AND WITHOUT OUTSIDE
CLIENTELE.
AND FINALLY WHEN A OPPORTUNITY
AROSE WHERE THAT --
POSITION OPENED UP IN THE
WORKSHOP I SUBMIT MY APPLICATION
AND RESUME.
AND I WAS HIRED ON AS A
ASSISTANT FILM EDITOR.
BASICALLY MY MIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE.
TO HELP THE STUDENTS ARMED WITH
THEIR VARIOUS PROJECTS AS WELL
AS OVERSEAS --
MAKE SURE OVERSEE THE VARIOUS --
FILMS AND OTHER VIDEOS THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH WE'RE
CURRENTLY ADDING [inaudible]
SO.
THANKFULLY LIKE I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THE FUTURES --
FOR EVERY OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS
ME.
I THINK YOU.
AND I NEXT UP WE'LL HEAR FROM
ALEX WHITE.
JUST SO YOU KNOW I I AM VERY
ARTISTIC SO PERHAPS I STUTTER A
LOT.
SO.
SO MY NAME IS ALEX WHITE I AM
I'M LIKE GOD I'M A CLIENT OF
FUTURES EXPLORED.
ERRED ON THE SONG I CURRENTLY
WORK LIKE THREE THREE JOBS SO
FAR I'M ONE OF THEM IS --
JANITORIAL AT THE FILM MEDIA
WHERE --
WHERE WHERE --
TONY HIT FOR TONI WORKS OUT
ANOTHER IS --
IS WORKING AT THE VICI WHICH IS
VOCATIONAL TRAINING EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAM WHICH IS ALSO WITH
FUTURES ON AND THERE I DO WHO
OFFICE WORK ON WEDNESDAY
MORNINGS AND THEN --
AND THEN THEN THEN THE NEXT JOB
I DO ON THURS AND FRIDAY THAT
THEM DO --
DO MAIL SERVICES AT THE
EDUCATIONAL DEPARTMENT.
AND THEIR DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
PLANET IT BUT I'M A PLUG IN.
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT IT AND AND A LOT.
SO I'M HAVE THE THAT THOSE PRINT
BUDGET AND IF YOU EVER CURIOUS
ABOUT WHAT KIND WORK I DO A
JANITORIAL ON THERE WE WE DID DO
OF THE FILL ME I DID DO A VIDEO
ARE.
ON JANUARY IT --
WHICH IS CALLED HIGHER ABLE IS
IT.
IT'S ON THE HIGHER ABLE WEBSITE.
HIGHER ABLED DOT ORG
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
AND THEN I'M AS WELL MENTIONED
WE HAVE A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL HERE DO AGAIN WHO
HAS A STATEMENT --
FROM ONE OF HIS ARM CLIENTS.
GOOD MORNING AMOUNT DUGAN IRISH
WITH FEATURES EXPORT I JUST WANT
TO READ A QUICK STATEMENT FROM
ONE OF OUR EMPLOYED A PERSON'S
TODAY WILL WAS CAUGHT A
COMMENTING ON EARLIER.
A GOOD MORNING EVERYONE AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY.
ABOUT HOW PROGRAMS LIKE FEATURES
EXPLORE PEOPLE FIND JOBS IN OUR
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
I'M.
DISABLED PEOPLE HAVE HAD MANY
STRUGGLES TO REACH OUR GOALS
EVERY DAY.
MY BIGGEST GOAL WAS TO FIND A
STEADY JOB SO I COULD TAKE CARE
OF MY OWN FAMILY.
I WAS TRYING TO FIND A JOB WITH
NO LUCK THROUGH MY OWN JOB
SEARCHING.
I JOIN MANY JOB CLUBS THROUGHOUT
THE SACRAMENTO REGION AND HOPES
TO CONTINUE MY MOTIVATION
KEEPING TO LOOK FOR WORK.
WHEN I SPOKE WITH MY DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION COUNSELOR THEY
MENTIONED TO ME ABOUT AN
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THAT WAS
OFFERED THROUGH THE D. O. R.?
I JUMPED AT THE CHANCE TO BEGIN
TO CHANGE MY FUTURE.
UPON WORKING TOWARDS GETTING AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION I WAS ALSO
WORKING WITH FUTURES EXPLORED.
I'VE HAD TO WORK WITH SOME OF
THEIR STAFF BEFORE ON OTHER
ASSIGNMENTS AND THEY KNOW HOW
PASSIONATE I AM ABOUT WORKING
HARD SETTING GOALS AND ASKING
FOR HELP WHEN THEY NEED IT.
I HOPE THAT MY STORY WILL TOUCH
MANY PEOPLE IN THE HOPES THAT
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO REACH
TOWARDS THE SKY.
AND NEVER GIVE UP.
THANK YOU KAREN MCCOY.
IF I COULD JUST ADD A COUPLE
THINGS WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY IN THE CAPACITY THAT I
DO.
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO GO AND JUST
MEET SOME FANTASTIC PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GO
NOT ONLY WORK A STEADY JOB BUT
TO BE ABLE TO GO AND PROVIDE A
WAY FOR THEM TO GO AND INTERACT
WITH EVERYBODY IN THE COMMUNITY.
OUR PROGRAMS INCLUDE PEOPLE THAT
GO AND WORK IN THE FAST FOOD
INDUSTRY OR PEOPLE LIKE ALEX TO
WORKING GENERAL CLERICAL.
AND THEIR BROADBAND PEOPLE AND
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT DESERVE
JOBS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M SO THE M..
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM THAT KIRA
TALKED ABOUT AND ALSO THAT
POLITICS WORKS THROUGH --
AT EDTA IS AS A RESULT OF S. B.
SIX FORTY FOUR WHICH WAS PASSED
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO THAT PILOT
STARTED LAST YEAR WE HAVE --
SIX INTERNS WORKING IN VARIOUS
STATE DEPARTMENTS --
WE'VE HAD INTERNS AND CAL AND
PARTNER OF REHABILITATION AND
PARTNER GENERAL SERVICES.
WE'VE HAD TWO HIRES SO FAR OUT
OF THAT --
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
FABULOUS --
BOTH OF THEM ARE WITH DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION.
AND AND SO WE HOPE AND WE SEE
THAT AS A REALLY GREAT PATHWAYS
FOR PEOPLE TO OBTAIN.
NOT ONLY EXPERIENCE THAT HELPS
THEM BUT HOPEFULLY ALSO STATE
EMPLOYMENT WHICH IS A HUGE GOAL
FOR A LOT OF THE POPULATION THAT
WE WORK WITH THE CITY.
STATE EMPLOYMENT AS KIND OF LIKE
A DREAM JOB.
AND IT'S BEEN --
UP UNTIL NOW REALLY HARD TO GET.
YOUR FOOT IN THE DOOR IF YOU
HAVE WELL FOR EVERYONE BUT
ESPECIALLY FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
SO THAT'S A REALLY GREAT PROGRAM
AND THAT'S A DIRECT RESULT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTION.
AND SO WILL ALSO ASKED ME TO
TALK ABOUT THE STAFFING SHORTAGE
ON I HAVE AS WELL SAID I'VE
WORKED IN THE FIELD ON FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS PRIMARILY AND
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT.
AND AND I SEE STAFFING SHORTAGE
AS ONE OF THE BIGGEST THREATS
AND DEFINITELY THE BIGGEST
BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I AM CURRENTLY.
IN THE PROGRAMS THAT I OVERSEE
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE --
OVER FORTY PEOPLE ON A WAIT LIST
WHO WANT JOB SEEKING SUPPORT --
AND WE'D JUST CANNOT HIRE STAFF
TO SERVE THOSE PEOPLE.
SO THAT MEANS THAT THE WANT TO
GET A JOB BUT THEY'RE WAITING
FOR SOMETIMES MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS BEFORE WE HAD STAFFING
AVAILABLE TO WORK WITH THEM.
AND THE STAFFING SHORTAGE.
STEMS FROM TWO THINGS AND THEY
ARE RELATED.
AND ONE OF THEM IS THAT OUR
REIMBURSEMENT RATES DON'T ALLOW
US TO PAY PEOPLE A LIVABLE
PROFESSIONAL WAY EACH.
BANDS AND THE OTHER ONE IS THAT
DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS ARE
NOT SEEN AS PROFESSIONALS
[inaudible]
THAT --
THEY'RE NOT EVEN LISTED ON THE
BUREAU OF LABEL LABOR STATISTICS
AS A CAREER CHOICE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE JOB
DUTIES OF A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANT.
AND THEN YOU LEFT OUT THE JOB
DUTIES OF A DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL.
THEY MATCH UP LINE FOR LINE AND
THEN THE DUTIES OF A DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL GO ON EVEN
FURTHER THAN A CERTIFIED NURSING
ASSISTANTS DUTIES.
A CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANT IN
CALIFORNIA STARTS AT ABOUT
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
A DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA STARTS
AT BETWEEN ELEVEN AND THIRTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE.
IS THAT CERTIFICATION.
CERTIFIED NURSING ASSISTANTS ARE
SEEN AS A CAREER CHOICE IT'S A
PROFESSION IT'S RECOGNIZED AS A
PROFESSIONAL FIELD TO GO INTO
AND RECOGNIZED AS A LEGITIMATE
CAREER SOURCE I MEAN CAREER
[inaudible]
TWICE [inaudible]
AND DIRECTOR BARGE MEN DISCUSSED
THE INCREASE IN THE POPULATION
IN THIS FIELD IN THE UPCOMING
YEAR.
AND SHE AND OTHERS DISCUSS THE
VARIOUS SERVICE NEEDS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THIS FIELD AND
THAT WILL BE.
COMING IN THE FEW.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF DIRECT
SERVICE PROFESSIONALS IN MEETING
THE SYSTEMS CURRENT AND FUTURE
DEMANDS IS SECOND ONLY TO THE
PEOPLE WE SERVE.
THERE WITHOUT --
WELL TRAINED WELL PAID DIRECT
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS THERE IS
NO SERVICES AND THERE IS NOT A
SYSTEM WITHOUT THEM.
TOOL THANKFULLY I'M WILL CENTER
AGAIN DISORDERED TO FOLLOW UP I
DID PROVIDE FOR THE COMMITTEES
FOR A ROUGH OUTLINE OF
EMPLOYMENT VARIOUS CATEGORIES
AND THINGS THAT ARE IN THERE.
SOME ACTIONS THAT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN TO BEEN VERY POSITIVE S.
B. SIX FORTY FOUR WAS.
ONE THE IMPLEMENTATION THE PAID
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM AND THE
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT INCENTIVES WAS GREAT.
OUR CHALLENGE IS BEEN IN
IMPLEMENTATION --
LEGISLATION SOMETIMES PUTS IN
LOTS AND LOTS AND LOTS AND LOTS
AND LOTS AND LOTS OF DETAILS.
THAT MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT ON
THE GROUND FOR US ACTUALLY DO
THAT.
YOU WANT TO KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT'S
THE HAIR COLOR WOULD SEE I COLOR
WHO IT WAS THEIR SHOE SIZE WHEN
REALITY HOW TO LOOK AT JOBS.
AND SO HELPING US RELIEVE SOME
OF THAT WOULD BE A HUGE BENEFIT --
TO DO THAT AND AS LINSEY POINTED
OUT OUR ABILITY TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN STAFF.
IS A HUGE SINGS THE SUPPORT
EMPLOYMENT RATE IS THE SAME
WHETHER YOU'RE IN FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER SAN DIEGO OR THE
BAY AREA --
WHICH MEANS THERE'S VERY
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES IN COST
OF LIVING TO HOW DO YOU
ATTRACTED MAINTAIN STAFF.
THE OTHER ONE IS WE NEED THE
TOOLS AND AND THE CHAIRS
OPPOSITE LED --
AND WORK WITH US ON TRYING TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO MOVE
PEOPLE FROM MORE.
SEGREGATED SITUATIONS TO MORE
COMMUNITY BASED WE GOT CLOSE THE
FINISH LINE BUT WAS VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR SO I THINK.
WE NEED THOSE EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE TO GIVE US THE
FLEXIBILITY AND AS LINDSAY
POINTED OUT.
IT AS WE MOVE MORE MOURNED
COMPLIANCE WITH BEING MORE MORE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO HAVE STAFF WHO ARE
VERY COMPETENT WERE ABLE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH ON MY VERY TRUSTS
WERE THERE IN RESPECTFUL OF OUR
FOLKS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT A LINE OF
SIGHT SUPERVISION.
IN A LARGE YOU KNOW DAY PROGRAM
OR WORK ACTIVITY CENTER OR OTHER
CONCRETE SETTING.
THERE'S A LOT OF LINE OF SIGHT
SUPERVISION.
BUT WHEN YOU TAKE TWO OR THREE
ONE TWO OR THREE FOLKS AND THE
COMMUNITY.
YOU'RE THEN TRUST IN THEM RIGHT
NOW AS I OFTEN SAY I'VE SEVEN
HER FOLKS WHO WERE SUPPORTING
RIGHT NOW.
IN PROBABLY SEVEN COUNTIES WITH
TWO HUNDRED PLUS STAFF.
AND I'M HOPING OF THE GOES WELL
TODAY.
YOU KNOW ITS REALLY DEPEND ON
THOSE FOLKS THAT MAKE THOSE
LIVES MEAN PHONE THAT'S REALLY
THE OPTION OF OUR EXERCISE HOW
TO MAKE THEIR LIVES MEANINGFUL.
EMPLOYMENT IS ONE HUGE KIVA THAT
IF YOU LOOK AT STATISTICS.
WE HAVE SEVENTY THOUSAND FOLKS
CLUSTERING DAY SERVICES WE HAVE
FIVE THOUSAND OUR LAST TOUR IN
SUPPORT EMPLOYMENT INDIVIDUAL
PLACEMENT.
THAT'S A HUGE SHIP THAT WE HAVE
FOR HOW TO DO SO WHAT THINGS
WERE OPEN COMMITTEE CAN LOOK AT
IT IS TO TAKE THAT ON AND GLAD
FOR THEM TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
FOR YOU BECAUSE THEY'RE MUCH
MORE THAN I A STRONG.
WELL MR CENTER YOU KNOW I HAVE
HAD A LONG RELATIONSHIP AND AND
I'VE ALWAYS APPRECIATED YOUR
CANDOR.
AND YOUR ENTHUSIASM --
I WILL SAY THAT --
AND YOUR EXPERTISE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEEN A GUIDING STAR FOR ME.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE INTEGRATED
WORK WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT STUFF
THAT?
WE CAN WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE --
HOPEFULLY IN THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION --
KNOWING THAT DAYS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE SUPPORT.
OTHER COMMUNITY WANTS TO BE
SUPPORTED INTO THE WORKFORCE --
BUT COULD YOU SHARE WITH ME AND
THE TWO HUNDRED PLUS OF
EMPLOYEES THAT YOU HAVE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT PRETENSION ALSO WHEN YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS GOING.
ABLE TO PAY.
FROM ELEVEN TO THIRTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR HOW LONG.
DO YOUR EMPLOYEES TEND TO LAST.
WE HAVE IT'S A RANGE OUR
TURNOVER RATE DEPEND HOW YOU
LOOK AT ITS ROUGHLY 23% A YEAR --
IF YOU GO INTO LESSEN THE YEAR
IT'S CLOSER TO FIFTY OR 55% --
IF SOMEONE COMES IN REALLY BUYS
INTO WHAT WE DO GETS A VELOCITY
ENJOYS THAT AS ONE TO WORK TWO
MAYBE THREE OTHER JOBS --
THEY'LL STAY AND SO WE HAVE
FOLKS ABOUT. 40% OF OUR FOLKS
HAVE BEEN WAS FOR LONGER THAN
THREE YEARS SO IT'S IS PRO THE
BIGGEST FOUNTAIN IT VARIES --
RADICALLY BASED ON LOCATION
BASED ON WHAT THE OTHER LOCAL
ECONOMY BEEN.
THE BAY AREA WE WERE COMPETING
WITH GOOGLE TWITTER SIGN ALL
THAT AND SO IT'S THAT THE
CHOICES OUT THERE IS HOW YOU
MAKE IT MEANINGFUL FOR FOLKS
BILL TO GO DO IT.
SO.
AS A MATTER OF FACT.
THROUGH SPECIAL OLYMPIC SITE
STARTED PROGRAM A MILE CAPITAL
WE'VE HAD IT FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AS A PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IT INTERNS WAS
SPECIAL NEEDS --
AND IT'S BEEN AN ATHLETE.
WONDERFUL EXPERIENCE HOW WE
LEARN FROM THEM HOW WE CAN
BETTER ADVOCATE.
AND IN THE WORKFORCE SPOKE.
MOODY'S OVER THERE IN THE CORNER
WON'T RAISE YOUR HAND RUDY.
WHO'S WITH THE SPECIAL EFFECTS --
WELL WHO IS ARE ESPEIALLY MIX
IN TURN IN IS A JOY TO WORK WITH
AND I WON AND HERE TODAY SO.
HE CAN GIVE ME FEEDBACK ALSO OF
THIS AFTERNOON.
ON WHAT WE CAN DO TO ACTUALLY --
BE A BETTER SUPPORT SYSTEM GOING
FORWARD --
BUT WE WANT YOU GUYS TO TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
IF WE'RE GONNA DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN. TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT YOU --
IN YOUR IN YOUR AND YOU KNOW
YOUR ABILITIES TO WORK WE WANT
YOU TO BE ABLE TO EXCEL SENDING
IN AND FEEL LIKE YOU'RE PART OF
CAN I ASK HOW MUCH.
SO YOU BOTH YOU MAKE OUR SO SO --
WELL WELL FOR THE WHAT WHAT WE
WE BUT USUALLY FOR ME IT'S LIKE
MINERAL WAGE.
AGENT.
A JOB WITH THE ECHO [inaudible]
LIKE HIM.
SO FOR SO FOR THE HOURS THAT WE
WORK AT UP SO FOR JANITORIAL ON
MONDAYS AND TUESDAYS I WORK.
I I WORK WITH WHAT WHEN THAT FOR
THE CLASS IT IS THAT THEY HAVE
THERE ARE OVER FOR THE DAY WHICH
IS THAT THREE AND THEN I WORKED
FOR TWO HOURS ON MONDAYS AND
TUESDAYS.
ON WEDNESDAY MORNING IF IT'S
THREE AND A HALF I THINK EIGHT
THIRTY TO TWELVE OVER AND OVER
AT THE VICI OFFICE AND THEN --
THAT -- THAT
MEDIA.
WHICH IS ON THE ONE THAT I I
CAN'T.
DON'T YOUNG CAPITAL I WORK FROM.
NINE THIRTY TO TWO THIRTY A IT'S
A ARE WHAT OTHER THAN FRIDAY'S.
AND YOU LIVE AT HOME.
YES THEY DO OKAY AT C..
I BELIEVE I WORK CURRENTLY --
WORK --
TWELVE FOR TWELVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR RIGHT NOW I WORK FIVE DAYS
A WEEK ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF
HOURS [inaudible]
CUTTING -- I
BELIEVE I DO I GUESS.
YES I DO I ALSO HAVE HEALTH
HEALTH BENEFITS --
WITH A THAT I HELD TO THAT --
HE CUT THROUGH I'M GOING THROUGH
FUTURE SIERRA.
I CAN AND YOU LIVE AT HOME STILL --
I CURRENTLY LIVE WITH MY SISTER
AND HER BOYFRIEND BUT I DO PAY
RENT [inaudible]
IF YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS PANEL HOW IT'S BEEN
ENLIGHTENING IN AGAIN --
YOU ARE CHAMPIONS KEEP GOING
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR
SAFETY NET AND CONSUMERS IN
CRISIS A EVELYN.
ABU HAMZA HOUSE PASSING.
I I BY BUTCHERED EVERY TIME
[inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY
HELLO
.
SHARES WITH WHEELS ALWAYS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
UP MY NAME IS AB ONE AB HASEN
I'M THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
I WAS ASKED TO TALK LITTLE BIT
ABOUT DRC.
AND THE WORK THAT WE DO AND THEN
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SAFETY NET.
AND CRISIS SERVICES.
SO LET ME START BY SAYING THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
BEFORE THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
AS I SAID I'VE EVELYN ABA
HUFFING AND SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
DRC IS THE EVEN FEE MANDATED BY
FEDERAL LAW TO PROTECT.
AND ADVOCATE FOR THE RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING THOSE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
OUR OFFICE OF CLIENTS RIGHTS
ADVOCACY OWES VERY.
ALSO PROVIDES ADVOCACY SERVICES
TO CONSUMERS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
THROUGH A CONTRACT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
THE R. C. PROVIDES LEGAL ANOTHER
ADVOCACY ASSISTANCE TO
APPROXIMATELY.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
INCLUDING HER LEVIN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
INDIVIDUALS.
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE PROVIDE BOTH SYSTEMIC
ADVOCACY AND INDIVIDUAL ADVOCACY
SERVICES [inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES WE
ACHIEVED.
OUR WORK THIS YEAR RESULTANT OUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN SERVICES
AND BENEFITS.
I CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES.
OUR REGIONAL CENTER.
PLANTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES HAVE THE
STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY TO
REPRESENT INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN
RESTRICTIVE ARRANGEMENTS.
AND IT'S THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE WHO MOST OFTEN EXPERIENCE
BEHAVIORAL CHALLENGES AS A
RESULT OF CRISIS.
I'M NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
HISTORY OF LEARNED DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT OF THAT TODAY SO
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS JUST TALK
MORE ABOUT THE SAFETY NET.
AND SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA HOUSE.
AS A RESULT OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICE TASK FORCE CONVENED BY
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
THERE'S A CLEAR CONSENSUS ABOUT
HOW THE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
SYSTEM CAN EFFECTIVELY RESPOND
TO CRISIS.
THE INDIVIDUALS FACE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE REPORT IDENTIFIES THE
GOALS OF THE DD CRISIS RESPONSE
SYSTEM TO BE.
ENSURING CONSUMER SAFETY.
WHICH INCLUDES PROTECTING
INDIVIDUALS FROM HARM AND ABUSE.
AND PROVIDING APPROPRIATE CRISIS
INTERVENTION AND RESPONSE.
WELL OF A WIDE VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES CAN RESULT IN
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ENDING UP IN CRISIS.
SUCH AS THE TERMINATION OF A
CURRENT LIVING ARRANGEMENT OR
SUPPORT SERVICES.
AND INCREASING BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES OR PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY.
THE TASK FORCE REPORT IDENTIFIED
AND EFFECTIVE CRISIS
INTERVENTION SYSTEM MUST INCLUDE.
PREVENTING A CRISIS FROM
OCCURRING INCLUDING.
MAINTAINING INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR HOMES AND DEVELOPING
MODELS OF SUPPORT SUPPORT. TO
PREVENT AN INDIVIDUAL FROM*
BECOMING INVOLVED IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM OR
NEEDING MORE RESTRICTIVE LEVEL
OF CARE.
THE DEPARTMENTS MAY TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SAFETY THAT REPORT
WHICH OF MISS BARTMAN REFER TO
ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS AT ANY GIVEN TIME.
WHO ARE HAVING A DEVELOPMENT WHO
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
ARE HAVING A CRISIS?
CURRENTLY THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
CERTAIN MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES.
INSTITUTES OF MENTAL DISEASE.
OR STATE OPERATED ACUTE CRISIS
[inaudible]
CENTERS.
IN ADDITION TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
DRC KNOWS OF HUNDREDS MORE
CONSUMERS WHO NEED CRISIS
SERVICES.
BUT HAVE NOT YET REACHED THE
CRITERIA THAT MAKES THEM
ELIGIBLE --
IN IT ED BUT MAY REACH THAT THAT
CRITERIA LEVEL IF APPROPRIATE
SERVICES ARE NOT PROVIDED.
SO HOW DO WE ASSIST CONSTITUENTS
AND OTHERS THAT REACH OUT AND
CRISIS.
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
LOOKS WHO EXPERIENCE OR ARE AT
RISK OF CRISIS SHOULD RECEIVE
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES
FROM THE LOCAL REGIONAL CENTER.
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S
OFFICE OF CLIENTS RIGHT ADVOCACY
MAY BE ABLE TO ASSIST IMAGE
ASSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVE THE SERVICES.
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS.
ARE APPROPRIATELY ASSESSED. ONE
STRATEGY FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE AT RISK OF LOSING THEIR
COMMUNITY PLACEMENT IS TO ASK
THE REGIONAL CENTER. TO REFER
THEM FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
ASSESSMENT PURSUANT TO WELFARE
AN INSTITUTION CODE. FORTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN POINT.
SEVEN THIS EVALUATION CAREFULLY
EXAMINES THE BEHAVIORS AND
SERVICES NEEDED TO MAINTAIN THE
PERSON IN THE COMMUNITY.
THE GOAL SHOULD BE KEEP THE
INDIVIDUAL LIVING IN THEIR HOME
OR THE RESIDENTIAL LIVING
ARRANGEMENT.
WITH ADDITIONAL SERVICES.
I'M TO ADDRESS THEIR BEHAVIOR
CHALLENGES.
THE NASE THE NEAREST REACH
REGIONAL RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS.
CONDUCT THESE ASSESSMENTS.
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES THE DEPARTMENT AS
ALREADY NOTED HAS CREATED THE
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN STAR.
WHICH ARE THE STABILIZATION
TRAINING ASSISTANCE AND
REGENERATION HOMES AND THE STAR
CRISIS A TH ASSESSMENT RESPONSE
TEAM THE CAST.
AND WHILE THE SERVICES INCLUDE
WELL TRAINED STAFF THEY ARE
LOCATED A LONG DISTANCE FROM THE
CONSUMERS AND CANNOT BE ALWAYS
THE INITIAL FIRST RESPONDER AND
A CRISIS.
AND WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE TWO COMMUNITY CRISIS
HOMES THAT ARE RUNNING --
THE AVAILABILITY OF BETSY IS
EXTREMELY LIMITED.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ENHANCE
BEHAVIORAL HOMES AGAIN THESE ARE
TWENTY FOUR HOUR RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED HOWEVER CURRENTLY
THEY ARE PRIMARILY PRIMARILY
FILLED.
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER MOVIES
UP MOVERS.
SO THE NEED FOR INCREASED
FUNDING IN THE COMMUNITY --
FOR SAFETY NET SERVICES WE DO
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS ON IN
IMPLEMENTING THE SAFETY NET PLAN
INCLUDING DEVELOPING THE NEW
MODELS OF CARE HOWEVER.
WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT GAPS THAT REMAIN.
AND THE INDIVIDUALS OF AND THAT
FOR SOME INDIVIDUALS THE CRISIS
THAT SYSTEM LOOKS MORE LIKE A
PATCHWORK OF SERVICES.
OPERATED BY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
RATHER THAN A COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM THAT WILL WILL MEET THE
DS TASKFORCE GOALS.
AND FOR EXAMPLE IN ONE WEEK.
OR IN SOME REGIONAL CENTER
CATCHMENT AREAS THERE ARE VERY
FEW LOCAL CRISIS RESPONSE
SERVICES AND THAT WHILE THE DHEA
DDS MOBILE CRISIS TEAM CAN HELP
IDENTIFY INTERVENTIONS.
THEY CANNOT QUICKLY RESPOND IN
CASES OF EMERGENCIES AND ALL
AREAS.
IN ADDITION WE KNOW THAT IN SOME
COUNTIES MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN COUNTY DESIGNATED
MENTAL HEALTH.
UTILITIES DECLINED TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
BECAUSE OF AN INCOMPLETE SYSTEM.
THESE INDIVIDUALS OFTEN.
END UP IN PLACES OF LIKE LOCKED
INSTITUTES OF MENTAL DISEASE
WHICH HAVE A VERY HIGH USAGE OF
SECLUSION.
AND RESTRAINT.
BUT WE ARE AWARE THAT SOME
REGIONAL CENTERS WHO DO NOT HAVE
OTHER OPTIONS ARE USING WHAT'S
KNOWN AS HOTEL THERAPY.
WHICH PLACES AN INDIVIDUAL IN
CRISIS IN A HOTEL WITH TO THE
ONE STAFFING AND TWENTY OF
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
WE REMAIN CONCERNED THAT
ADDITIONAL SAFETY NET CAPACITY --
IT BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE
ADDITIONAL SAFETY NET COMMIT
CAPACITY AT THE CURRENT --
CAPACITY IS INSUFFICIENT TO MEET
THE NEED.
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
INCREASED SAFETY NET FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LOCAL CRISIS
CAPACITY.
SO THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIORAL.
CHALLENGES CAN BE SUPPORTED IN
THEIR CURRENT LIVING ARRANGEMENT
[inaudible]
WITH -- IN
ORDER TO PIN UP PREVENT
PLACEMENT AND RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS LIKE INSTITUTES FOR
MENTAL DISEASE OR OTHER MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES.
THUS WE SUGGEST WHAT BONDS NEED
TO BE TARGETED FOR THE FOLLOWING
TYPES OF SERVICES.
MOBILE CRISIS SERVICES IN EACH
REGIONAL CENTER CATCHMENT AREA
AGAIN WE TALKED ABOUT THE
SERVICES THERE.
THEY ARE NOW AVAILABLE BUT THEY
ARE VERY HARD TO ACCESS --
AND IN EACH REGIONAL CENTER AREA.
COMPREHENSIVE INDIVIDUAL
ASSESSMENT PLANNING AND TAILORED
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS. TO PROVIDE A CONTINUITY
OF TREATMENT --
TREATMENT SUPPORTS INTENSIVE
MONITORING.
CASE MANAGEMENT AND I THINK MISS
WAS LIKE TALK ABOUT THIS
REDUCING CASE A SERVICE CASELOAD
RUSHED RATIOS PART THIS
POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS.
DEVELOPMENT OF INTENSIVE OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR PERSONS
WITH CO OCCURRING DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND MENTAL HEALTH.
NEEDS THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE DUAL DIAGNOSES.
THE YOU SERVICES WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO SUCCESSFULLY
PREVENT ADMISSION INTO HIGHLY
RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS LIKE
INSTITUTES OF MENTAL DISEASE WE
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LACK OF LACK OF MOVEMENT
FROM INDIVIDUALS.
OUT OF I'M.
INSTITUTES A MENTAL DISEASE THEY
OFTEN STAY THERE BEYOND THE
STATUTORY TIMELINE OF A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DAYS.
SO I'M TOO OFTEN OF REGIONAL
CENTERS DO NOT DEVELOP PLANS TO
MOVE THESE INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
THESE TYPES OF SETTINGS.
AND FINALLY INCREASING THE
NUMBER AND TYPES OF COMMUTING
THE CRISIS LIVING ARRANGEMENTS --
AVAILABLE IN THE COMMUNITY FOR
THIS POPULATION OF INDIVIDUALS
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGH
NEEDS AND AGAIN WE BUT WE NEED
TO SEE MORE.
OF COMMUNITY LIVING ARRANGEMENTS
FOR THEM --
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER IT.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITH THAT AND WE ALL HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SAFETY NET HIS
[inaudible]
IMPERATIVE.
WITH THE S. POPULATION BEING
ABLE TO BE --
SERVED INTO IT TO AN EXTENT
WHERE.
IF THERE IS.
A NEED HERE IT IS INSTANTANEOUS --
BECAUSE OF THE FRAGILE STATE
THAT SOME FOLKS GET IN IN ANY
GIVEN THE BEHAVIORAL --
ASPECT THEY CAN GET IN MORE
TROUBLE XIN NOT THIRTIES TO
CATCH THEM --
SO.
I LOOK FORWARD.
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND I WORKING
WITH YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE
WORKING WITH YOU WHERE WE CAN.
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN IMPROVE ON
THAT SAFETY NET ALSO GOING
FORWARD AND HELIPORT YOUR
EXPERTISE.
WE'VE PROVIDED SOME DETAILED
MATERIALS IN YOUR PACKET STATE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO REACH OUT TO
US AT DRC FOR ANY KIND OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE --
DEATHLY WE'RE GONNA BE USING YOU
AS A REFERENCE POINT FOR A LOT
OF A LOT OF THINGS WERE --
AND THE COMMUNICATION CONTINUES
THROUGHOUT THE RECESS UNTIL THE
NEXT WEBSITE CYCLE I SAY THE THE
WHOLE POINT I THINK.
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE HEAR
THE COMMUNITY.
AND I PASSED --
OF THE LEGISLATURE THE ASSEMBLY.
FOR AT LEAST ONE BILL TO BE
CARRIED PER ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR
THIS COMMUNITY AND IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT SADIE BILLS.
ARE GOING FORWARD WITH A
COMMITMENT TO CATCHING UP AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE.
APPROACH WHERE WE CAN CONNECT
THE DOTS.
AND HENDO SHOW THAT.
IT'S TIME TO CATCH UP.
SO REALLY APPRECIATE WORKAWAY
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
HAPPY TO BE HERE THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT WE'LL DO IS MOVE ON
TO OUR UP PUBLIC COMMENT --
IN THE INDIVIDUALS IN THE PUBLIC
WHO LIKE TO MAKE.
BUT A TO TWO MINUTE --
COMMENT --
EACH.
HOW COME ON UP TO THE MIKE?
THE SERGEANTS WILL HELP YOU.
SO WHAT I'LL DO IS ASK YOU TO
STATE YOUR NAME AND WHERE YOU'RE
FROM [inaudible]
AND THEY ALSO A BIT ABOUT
YOURSELF WHICH WOULD PUT YOU
HERE.
FOR HELLO MY NAME IS MOHAMMED
RASHID I AM WERE REPRESENTING
VALLEY NOW AND REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I AM A CONSUMER
REPRESENTATIVE ON THEIR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND I'M HERE TO TALK
TO YOU GUYS ABOUT THAT
[inaudible]
PAT [inaudible]
THE BIGGEST.
I HAD TROUBLE THAT PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES HAVE
[inaudible]
TRANSPORTATION.
BECAUSE IT'S SO LIMITED AND
THERE.
THE TIME OF THAT THE THE
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE
[inaudible]
ARMED.
IT'S NOT VERY CONDUCIVE TO A
PERSON WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ITEM.
LIFE THE UP.
GOOD TIME LIMITS VERY SHORT I..
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR
PERSON TO HAVE FUN ESPECIALLY ON
WEEKENDS WHEN THERE'S NO
TRANSPORTATION --
FOUR PEOPLE DITCH DISABILITIES
OF AND THERE'S ALSO [inaudible]
NOT ENOUGH.
TRAINING WITH BUS DRIVERS I'VE
NOTICED THAT.
SOME DRIVERS DON'T KNOW HOW TO
REALLY.
APPROPRIATELY TREAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARM I'VE BEEN I
HAVE.
A VICTIM OF THAT --
BUT NOT.
ONLY IN THE I I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE OF A OPEN TIME.
OF TRANSPORTATION ORDERS NOT.
ANY OF LIMIT OF TRANSPORTATION.
OF FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT ARE
THINKING.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND WHO
YOU REPRESENT PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS JACKIE DELUDE VOSS
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTIVE LIVING NETWORK AND
I'M ALSO A PROVIDER HERE LOCALLY
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA WITH THE
STEP PROGRAM --
ONE IS YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE YOU ASKED ABOUT
TURNOVER RATE I WAS JUST INVITED
WITH TO THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
FOR THE INTELLECTUALLY AND
DEVELOP ONLY DISABLED THEY SAY
TO THEY HAVE TO ME LOOK I'M.
LETTERS IN THEIR NAME TO THE
NATIONAL WORKFORCE CRISIS AND
WHAT THEY REPORTED THERE WAS
NATIONALLY THERE SEEN A 40%
TURNOVER RATE.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
MODELS RESIDENTIAL UTAH FOR
EXAMPLE THERE RESIDENTIAL MODEL
USED AND 80% TURNOVER RATE.
AYE KNOW THAT IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE PROBABLY HAD
THE 4250% YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE MODELS OF CARE AND THE WAGES
AS WELL.
SO THE WORKFORCE CRISIS THE
SUPPORTIVE LIVING NETWORK HAS
DETERMINED TO THINGS THE
WORKFORCE PRICES THE HOUSING
CRISIS IF THOSE AREN'T SOLVED
CURRENTLY I HAVE TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT SUPPORTIVE
LIVING.
FROM MY AGENCY AND I CAN'T
PROVIDE.
THEY DON'T HAVE STAFFING I CAN'T
PROVIDE THE BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
HOUSING.
I WAS -- ON
A THREAD WITH A PROVIDER FROM
SANTA CRUZ SHE HAS A GENTLEMAN
THAT WAS A NAY SECTION EIGHT
HOUSING FOR TWENTY YEARS THEY
REMODELED THE HOUSING UNIT.
HE IS IN A HOTEL.
THEN ANOTHER PERSON PIPED UP
THERE IN ORANGE COUNTY THIRTY
YEARS SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER THEY
REMODELED THE UNIT THEY ARE NOW
HOMELESS AS WELL MY AGENCY HAS
TO INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES BOTH WITH VOUCHERS
[inaudible]
BOTH DO NOT HAVE HOUSING RIGHT
NOW.
IT IS AN ABSOLUTE HORRENDOUS
STATEWIDE CRISIS IT FROM
SACRAMENTO TO ORANGE COUNTY TO
THE BAY AREA TO SANTA CRUZ YOU
CAN EVEN GO INTO READING.
I SIR FOLKS IN YUBA CITY IT'S A
HOUSING CRISIS FOLKS CANNOT LIVE
IN IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
HOUSING CRISIS I WANT YOU TO
APPLY IT TO DIRECT SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL WHO'S NOW MAKING
ELEVEN TO THIRTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR BECAUSE THAT'S ABOUT THE
AVERAGE.
WHERE THEY LIVING?
WHERE THEY LIVE IN AS WELL SO WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS WITHIN OUR
POPULATION THEY HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE WORKFORCE CRISIS HIKE I
AGREE EMPLOYMENT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF OUR FOLKS
TO HAVE?
A WHICH THEY NEED TO HAVE A WAGE
THAT'S NOT JUST I HAVE MINIMUM
WAGE. FOR FIVE HOURS A WEEK THEY
NEED A FULL TIME JOB TO BE ABLE
TO SAYS SURVIVE IN THIS ECONOMY
RIGHT NOW SO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THOSE TWO ISSUES WE HAVE GOT TO
ADDRESS THE WAGES.
I THINK LINDSAY WITH THEM A
FUTURE EXPLORED SAID IT REALLY
ELOQUENTLY.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN LOOKED AT AS A
PROFESSIONAL LOOK AT THE LIST OF
WHAT THEY DO OR TALK ABOUT FOLKS
WITH VERY COMPLEX NEEDS.
I'M FORTUNATE IN THAT MY AGENCY
WILL OPEN ONE OF THE CRISIS
HOMES AYE AUGUST THIRTEENTH WILL
BE THE FIRST PERSON COMING INTO
ONE OF THOSE CRISIS HOMES.
AND THE WAGES FOR THOSE STAFF IS
GOING TO BE A WAGE IT'LL
PROBABLY BE LIVABLE BUT I HAVE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OF LIVING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SAME COMPLEX
BEHAVIORS THAT WE HAVE MODEL
TOGETHER SUPPORT. FOR YEARS AND
YEARS.
FOLKS WITH AUTISM THAT HAVE VERY
SIGNIFICANT BEHAVIOR CRISIS AND
MOST STAFF KNOW I WALK IN THE
DOOR AND I KNOW TODAY I'LL
PROBABLY BE HIT.
I'LL PROBABLY GET PAID THIRTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR TO BE HIT SO WE
NEED A STATE OF CALIFORNIA
DECIDE WE RESPECT THESE
PROFESSIONALS.
AND LET'S MAKE THEIR WAGE
REFLECTIVE OF THE RESPECT THAT
THEY THEY SHOULD EXPECT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHICH NAME TO REPRESENT PLEASE
MY NAME IS JAMIE DAVIS I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MY
ADVENTURES AT THE SMALL DAY
PROGRAM IN MARIN COUNTY CENTER
FILE -- I
STARTED OUT THIRTY ONE YEARS AGO
THIS WEEK AT FIVE TWENTY THREE
AN HOUR.
AS A RESIDENTIAL TECHNICIAN AND
AN INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITY --
I HAD A COLLEGE DEGREE AND MY
PARENTS WERE LIKE WHAT ARE YOU
DOING.
BUT IT BECAME A PROFESSION FOR
ME AND I FEEL LIKE I'VE HAD I'VE
HAD A LOT OF LUCKY BREAKS.
THAT -- IN I
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE WHERE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO OUR CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES.
THE MOST RECENT CHALLENGE IN
THIS SORT OF WINCHESTER MYSTERY
HOUSE TO QUOTE WILL SANFORD OF
OUR RATE SETTING METHOD UP
METHODOLOGY IS HALF DAY BILLING.
WHICH WAS RE IMPLEMENTED THIS
YEAR.
WE DO A LOT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
TASK TO FIND OUT YOU KNOW. FOR
FOR PEOPLE FOR THREE DAYS WE
HAVE A HALF DAY OF BILLING. FOR
OTHER AGENCIES IT MIGHT BE MORE.
BUT THE HARD THING IS WE CAN'T
DO HALF DAY PAYMENT FOR OUR
STAFF.
SO THEY COME IN IN THE MORNING
AND THEY EXPECT WORK A FULL DAY.
AND THEY DO EVEN IF OUR CLIENTS.
YOU KNOW ONLY SPEND 65% OF THEIR
DAY THERE AND WE ONLY GET HALF
THE MONEY --
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CHALLENGES
LIKE THIS LIKE THE HOLIDAYS?
THE HOLIDAYS THAT WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED NEXT YEAR.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE IN OTHER KINDS
OF BUSINESSES SAY.
WELL THEN WHY ARE YOU STILL IN
BUSINESS.
HOW ARE YOU STILL IN BUSINESS?
AND I WOULD SAY.
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE OF OUR
BUILDINGS.
CUTTING BACK ON FRONTLINE
SUPERVISION [inaudible]
LOW WAGES.
COMPROMISE BENEFITS. FOR OUR
STAFF.
AND BASICALLY ROBBING THE
PROVERBIAL PETER TO PAY PAUL
PAUL TO PAY PETER YOU KNOW IT'S
LIKE.
HOW MY GET I'M STILL STRUGGLING
WITH MY BUDGET THIS YEAR?
AND THE REASON I'VE HAD I BEEN
IN THE BLACK THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IS.
I BASICALLY HAVE A 20% STAFFING
DEFICIT.
AND THAT'S HELPED ME.
GET THROUGH THE LAST TWO YEARS.
AND NOT EVERYBODY IS STILL IN
BUSINESS A DAY PROGRAM IN MARIN
COUNTY IS GOING OUT OF BUSINESS
THIS MONTH.
I THINK THE MORE IMPORTANT
QUESTION WE SAY WELL HOW ARE YOU
STILL IN BUSINESS IS WHY.
WHY DO I DO THIS?
WHY DID I WORK FOR LOW WAGES
MYSELF? TO GET TO WHERE I AM
TODAY.
IS BECAUSE THE PEOPLE.
I LOVE.
THE PEOPLE SOME OF THEM LIKE MY
OWN FAMILY I'VE KNOWN SINCE I
STARTED IN THE FIELD.
AND I KNOW OTHER PROVIDERS IN
THIS ROOM.
THAT HAVE JOBS.
WHERE THEY FEEL JOY EVERYDAY AND
NOT EVERYONE HAS THAT?
AND NOT EVERYONE HOUSE THE RICH
RELATIONSHIPS AT WORK THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DEVELOP FOR THE CLIENTS.
SO WHY WERE STILL IN BUSINESS IN
SPITE OF THE CHALLENGES IS.
BECAUSE WE LOVE THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE AND I HELP I GET TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THEM FOR ABOUT
TWENTY MORE YEARS.
THINK IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
VISION IMMIGRANT REPRESENT
PLEASE.
THANK YOU SANDY SOLID A ON THE
COORDINATOR OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES COUNCIL IT'S A
PROGRAM AND POLICY PLANNING UNIT
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO LEFT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I WANNA
TALK VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT THE WORK
FORCE ISSUE AND THE SAFETY NET
ISSUE.
ON JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
SNAPSHOT ON AND I DON'T THINK
THERE ARE MANY LEGISLATORS LEFT
IN CALIFORNIA WHO HAVEN'T HEARD
ME SAY MY DOG WALKERS MAKE MORE
MONEY.
THAN DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS CURRENTLY I PAY
TWENTY SEVEN DOLLARS FOR HALF AN
HOUR DAHLE GLOCK [inaudible]
ON IF THAT DOESN'T RESONATE WITH
YOU THEN I WILL SAY THAT MIGHT
CLERK ON A COUNTY CLERK SALARY
MAKES MORE MONEY THAN HAS JOB
COACH [inaudible]
ON WE WILL APPRECIATE THAT THE
RATE STUDY WE APPRECIATE THAT LA
OVER REPORT BUT BOTTOM LINE IS
OUR SYSTEM IS BASED ON A MINIMUM
WAGE MODEL.
AND INTEL THAT CHANGES WEEK PAT
GET.
THE WORKERS THAT WE NEED I HAVE
SOME DATA THAT UP WHEN I HEARD
THIS I THOUGHT IT WAS
FASCINATING THIS IS FROM ALEGRIA
COMMUNITY LIVING ALEGRIA HAS
EIGHT HOMES.
AND TWENTY SIX OF RESIDENTS AND
THEIR HOMES ON AT THE RESIDENTS
ARE FORMER I'VE FROM.
AGNES AND CINEMA DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTER SO IN ONE FISCAL YEAR
WHEN THEY WERE LOOKING FOR STAFF.
THEY REVIEWED THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY RESUMES
THEY DID TWENTY HUNDRED PLUS
CALLS 270-0 AND TWO POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES. FORTY NINE
CANDIDATES WERE NO SHOWS THIRTY
THREE CANDIDATES INTERVIEWED AND
NOT CHOSEN. THIRTY SEVEN
CANDIDATES INTERVIEWED AND HIRED
ELEVEN TERMINATED FOURTEEN OTHER
STAFF TERMINATE.
SO THAT'S ONE YEAR OF AN AGENCY
THAT SERVES TWENTY SIX RESIDENTS
AND HAS EIGHT HOMES SO THAT
AGAIN IS A SNAPSHOT.
JUST THEN VERY QUICKLY ABOUT THE
SAFETY NET SERVICES --
THE IT FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY OUR
RESIDENTS WILL UP RECEIVE LITTLE
OR NO BENEFIT FROM MEDICAL
SERVICES OUTSIDE THE COUNTY.
CURRENTLY ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS IF
NOT THE HIGHEST ONE OF THE
HIGHEST FIFTY ONE FIFTY RATES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANNA TELL YOU ABOUT ONE OF MY
BOARD MEMBER SIGN.
HE REACHED TRANSITION AGE HE
BECAME ACTIVATED HE BECAME
DANGEROUS SHE CALLED ON A NINE
ONE ONE ONE EVENING THEY TOOK
HIM TO USUALLY IT'S THEY TAKEN
TO JOHN GEORGE THAT GET BOUNCED
OUT OF JOHN GEORGE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL.
THIS TIME THEY TAKEN TO THE
FREMONT KAISER <c.green> ARE HE</c>
SPENT A WEEK IN THE ER HE SPENT
THREE WEEKS IN THE HOSPITAL.
BECAUSE ALAMEDA COUNTY AT THAT
TIME.
CRISIS HOME AND THERE WERE NO
BIDS OF THE FOUR BEDS IN THAT
HOME FINALLY HE WAS ABLE TO GO.
WE NEED THOSE SERVICES TO THANK
YOU.
RESEARCH MEMORY REPRESENT COULD
NOT DAN HOKA EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LOST CONFIDENCE IN CENTRAL
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WE SERVE.
A APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED TWENTY
INDIVIDUALS IN ADULT DAY
PROGRAMS AT ADULT RESIDENTIAL
SUPPORTED LIVING IN THE
INDEPENDENT LIVING SERVICES ARM.
I THINK ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT.
WHILE THE RATE STUDY IS COMING
OUT THAT WE NEED TO ALSO EXAMINE
IS THE ACTUAL STRUCTURE ARE ON
THE VENDOR CODES.
AND THE LIMITATIONS THAT IT
PLACES ON VENDORS ARE IN THAT IN
THE SERVICES THAT THEY ACTUALLY
PROVIDE.
SO AS WE MOVE TOWARD SELF
DETERMINATION IN INDIVIDUALS ARE
CHOOSING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
WANT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO REMEMBER IS THAT VENDORS
NOW NEED TO BECOME VERY FLEXIBLE.
IN CUSTOMIZING THE SERVICES TO
THE INDIVIDUAL SO IF YOU'RE
SAYING THAT IF YOU SAY THAT
YOU'VE YOU'RE PROVIDING AN ADULT
DAY PROGRAM SERVICES WHICH IS
VERY DEFINED.
AND SO FORTH BUT THE INDIVIDUAL
WANTS TO ALSO DO OTHER THINGS
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AS WELL THAT
ARE NOT WITHIN THAT.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE BAD
SERVICE CUTS AND I AGREE WITH
EVERYBODY HERE REGARDING THE
STAFFING OUR DAY PROGRAM WERE
DOWN 33% ON OUR STAFF RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE THE PROGRAMS. FOR PEOPLE
TO ATTEND WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
STAFF AND WE CAN'T STOP THEM.
THE OTHER DAY I HAD ACTUALLY
PROVIDE INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES TO ONE OF MY STAFF
BECAUSE SHE CAME TO ME INSERTED
TOLD ME.
THAT SHE LOST HER HOUSING.
AND HAD TO PROVIDE TO HER THE
COACHING IN THE MENTORING AND
THE RESOURCES THAT I WOULD TO
ANY OF OUR THE CLIENTS THAT WE
SERVE TO HELP.
HER FIND HOUSING FOR HERSELF.
THE IT IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE.
CAN NOW AND AGAIN. 33% DOWN IN
MY DAY PROGRAM. 25% DOWN IN
SUPPORTED LIVING I'VE HAD A 100%
TURNOVER IN MY EYELIDS PROGRAM
IN THE LAST YEAR.
THIS IS THIS IS UNSUSTAINABLE IT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED I
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
COMMITTEE TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OUT MY NAME IS MARTY
EMOTO I'M A FAMILY MEMBER MY
OLDER SISTER HAD DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ALSO WORKED IN THE
SYSTEM. FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO IS
A DIRECT CARE WORKER AND I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
A CD CAN'T TELL FROM DISPLACING
YOUR CREE ACTION NETWORK --
FORTY FORTY FIVE YEARS GOES
DIRECT CARE WORKER AND HAD A
HOLD TWO DIFFERENT JOBS TO
SUPPORT MY FAMILY.
AND I GUESS A LOT OF THINGS HAVE
CHANGE IN THE SYSTEM SINCE THEN
BUT ONE OF THINGS THAT DIDN'T
CHANGE IS THAT.
IS THAT PEOPLE STILL HAVE TO
WORK TWO JOBS OR FIND WAYS TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY IN TRYING.
TO TO HELP AND SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES FIRST WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER AND YOU
MISTER MULLIN AND IN THIS TO
HAVE -- AND
NOT THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UP FOR DOING THIS
HEARING BUT I THINK IT'S MORE
ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT.
THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE WHICH IS
THAT YOUR COMMITTED FOR THE NEXT
SIX YEARS OR MAYBE LONGER IF YOU
CAN FIND A WAY TO STAY LONGER.
I DON'T NOW YOU NEVER KNOW --
TWO CAN TO REALLY DO AND DRY
DRILL DOWN ON THE ISSUES ARE
IMPACT YOUR COMMUNITY WITH
ONGOING HEARINGS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE A
LOT OF PEOPLE OF YOU CAN TELL
FROM THIS ROOM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN'T MAKE UP TO
SACRAMENTO AND I REALLY PREACH
EFFECT THAT YOU YOU'RE COMMITTED
IN DOING THAT.
NUMBER TWO I'M JUST WANT TO SAY
YOU WERE ASKING FOR SOME STEPS
WHAT PEOPLE CAN DO IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
MAKE SURE THAT WERE INCLUDED OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDED IN OTHER
POLICY INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE
BROADER HOUSING PACKAGE.
YOU ARE THAT WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUT THERE'LL BE
OTHER HOUSING BILLS THAT WE
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IS ISSUES OF
HIGHER EDUCATION ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OUR WORKFORCE
OR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES NEED TO BE
MENTIONED IN THOSE THINGS.
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SUCH AS THE
FIRES I KNOW THAT SOMETIMES WERE
MENTION WE NEED TO BE MENTIONED
BECAUSE THAT DIRECTLY IMPACTS
OUR COMMUNITY --
NUMBER THREE REGARDING HOUSING
AND I WON'TREPEAT EVERYTHING
THAT OF THE OTHERS PEOPLE SET.
BUT WHEN YOU THINK OF HOUSING
PLEASE THINK ALSO.
OF OUR WORKFORCE THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER JUST MENTIONED IN A
SITUATION THAT IS NOT UNCOMMON.
OUR WORKFORCE IS PAID VERY LOW
THEY CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING MANY
OF THE WORKFORCE ARE MEDI CAL.
AND THEY NEED ASSISTANCE IN
ADDITION OUR FAMILIES WITH PEACH
YOUNG CHILDREN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES NEED
HOUSING AND THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED
IN ALL THOSE NUMBERS THAT YOU
JUST HEARD.
THIRD REPRIEVE SHAPE THE EFFORTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
REGARDING THE RATE STUDY IN THE
OTHER INITIATIVES --
BUT WANT TO MAKE AND I APPLAUD
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE INCLUDING A
FAMILY SURVEY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE INCLUDED THE
FAMILIES ARE INCLUDED IN HELPING
TO DO.
TO CONSTRUCT THAT SURVEY BUT WE
ALSO WANT URGED DEPARTMENT IN
THE STATE. TO INCLUDE PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN THAT SURVEY.
AND ALSO WHEN YOU SURVEY THE
FAMILY DEVELOPMENT OF ABILITIES.
YOUR SURVEY NOT JUST THE
SERVICES THEY GET BUT THE
SERVICES THEY AREN'T GETTING AND
THE SERVICES THAT YOU
DESPERATELY NEED.
AND THE OTHER.
ISSUE IS WHERE WE EVEN TALKED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT IS.
PUSHING WITH FOCUS GROUPS.
ACROSS THE STATE TO TALK ABOUT
THE RATES.
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE REGIONAL
CENTERS PROVIDERS AND FAMILIES
AND PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AS ANOTHER WAY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON HOW TO FIX OUR SYSTEM.
AND MAKE IT SUSTAINABLE LASTLY
JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN
OVER AND OVER WHICH YOU HEARD
ABOUT SAFETY NET ISSUES BUT IT'S
REALLY ABOUT RESPONDING TO
CRISIS MY SISTER WAS IN CRISIS.
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO AND PRIOR TO
THAT SHE WAS IN CONSTANT CRISIS
MY FAMILY HAD NOWHERE TO GO
[inaudible]
AND THAT JUSTICE THING THAT AS
SANDRA SMITH MENTION.
FAMILIES ARE DESPERATE AND WE'VE
GOT TO HAVE THE WAY ONE OF
PERSON WITH DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES OR THEIR FAMILIES
IN CRISIS THERE IS.
PLACE FOR THEM TO GO AND RECEIVE
HELP AND APPRECIATE ALL YOU'RE
DOING THANK YOU.
MY NAME OTHER IDEAS HAVE YOU.
ROOM YOU. FOR OTHER WORDS I
NEVER DID CHILDHOOD DAYS AND IS.
TO HOWEVER I'M A BOTH HERE IN
TWO HOURS AND WHEN WE GOT IN
THERE --
MUMUN WE WOULD TENTATIVE AND I
HAVE A BUT AS THE COMING YEAR ME --
KNOWN DRIVE OVER THERE WILL.
AND I HAD THEIR WAY AND TWO MORE
HOURS INTO THE HOME.
AND IT'S A HORRIBLE WHERE NO ONE
GO OUT TO HAVE FRAME AND WHERE
EACH IS EXPLORED AND NOW ONE OF
WILL'S 40%.
JUST PASSED MY ALMOST FOUR YEARS
NOW WITH THE COMPANY
[inaudible]
COME.
YEAH I'M I'M RARE NOTIONS A RARE.
ARM ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
CAN TALK ABOUT AS EMPLOYMENT FOR
OUR ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES
DISEASE XXI US WITH THE SETTING
UP INDEPENDENCE FOR ALL OF THE
GUYS THAT I'VE SERVICE AND HELP
GET JOBS.
IT'S JUST A REALLY OF REWARDING
FOR MYSELF.
TO SEE THAT WITH THEM AND THEIR
SUCCESS BOTH THE ONE THING IS
THAT SOME OF WHEN I DESCRIBE MY
JOB IS SOME FRIENDS AND FAMILY
SALE THAT'S SO GREAT THAT'S
WONDERFUL.
OUTCOMES MORE HOW CAN WE WORK
CREE GUYS.
NOW I SAY.
WELL YOU KNOW MONEY IS KIND AN
ISSUE RIGHT THERE.
THAT KIND OF TURNS ME OFF TO OUR
PROFESSION WHICH I BELIEVE THAT
I'M A PART OF RIGHT NOW.
THE HAVE THE PASSION FOR WHAT WE
DO THE IT IS A PROFESSION NOT
JUST A JOB IT'S AN ADVENTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL.
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AMPERSANDS LIKE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THEIR DEDICATION TO
THESE ISSUES --
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND YOUR EFFORT NESS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE IN A VERY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THE ISSUES
IN YOUR HEART MANY MANY OF THEM
HERE TODAY ANGLE HERE QUITE A
FEW MORE ANSWER AS YOU --
HAVE MORE HEARINGS AND LISTEN TO
THE STAKEHOLDERS BUT YOU KNOW
YOU'VE HEARD --
FROM WORK FORCE.
TO CALLS EVERY WEEK AROUND
ISSUES AROUND WORKFORCE HOUSING
CRIMINAL JUSTICE --
YOU KNOW MARTY MADE A REALLY%
REALLY GOOD POINT ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT --
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES ARE
INCLUDED IN ALL LEGISLATION
WHERE RELEVANT I THINK THAT THAT
IF THERE'S ONE TAKEAWAY I THINK
THAT THAT COULD BE THE HUGEST
ONE BECAUSE THAT WOULD COVER
EVERYTHING --
FROM TRANSPORTATION HOUSING THE
WORK FORCE I'M JUST THAT KNOWING
THAT --
THERE'S THAT I NEED TO LOOK A
LITTLE DEEPER AND AND ENSURE
THAT THERE'S FULL INCLUSION
ACROSS ALL POLICIES SO --
AGAIN I SAW REALLY WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
EFFORT AND WE WANT TO BE HERE
FOR RESOURCES YOU AND AS YOU
NOTICES LAW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALONE.
MISTER NOLAN YOU HAVE FOR A
CLOSING COMMENTS JUST VERY
BRIEFLY IMAGE CHAIR --
GRATEFUL TO YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP GRATEFUL TO EVERYONE
IN THE ROOM FOR SHARING YOUR
EXPERTISE.
A HOT WITH US --
THE NATURE OF THIS JOB IS THAT
WE ARE GENERALISTS.
AND WE RELY ON THE EXPERTISE OF
UP OF THOSE OF YOU IN THE ROOM
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT --
LIKE THE CHAIR I'M ON THAT SIX
YEAR TIME FRAME SO I AM FULLY
COMMITTED TO A WORKING THIS
ISSUE AT LEAST FOR THOSE SIX
YEARS BUT WE ARE ALSO IN A
WINDOW RIGHT NOW --
IN ADVANCE OF A RECESSION.
WHERE WE HAVE RESOURCES WE HAVE
A RATES THAT BECOMING A WE DO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE TO PUSH
THIS?
AGGRESSIVELY HOW MISTER CHAIR
AND I WOULD LIKE TO UTILIZE.
THAT WINDOW WHILE WE HAVE IT AND
WE DO HAVE RESOURCES --
TO STABILIZE THE SYSTEM GOING
FORWARD SO THANK YOU OUTLOOK FOR
TO PARTNER WITH YOU MISTER.
THAT MISTER MULLIN.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
THE PASSION AND DEDICATION FOR
THIS COMMUNITIES FELT THAT IN
THIS ROMAN AMONGST US.
TODAY'S TESTIMONY IS HIGHLIGHTED
THE NEED FOR INCREASED SUPPORT.
DRAMATICALLY AND I WANT TO THANK
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TEAM FOR
BEING HERE TODAY FROM DTS.
SON KNOWS BEING TAKEN AND A LOOK
FORWARD TO COLLABORATION WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WITH DTS.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ACCOMMODATE
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING
FORWARD.
AND NOT STANDING STILL ANYMORE
OF WITH THE INCREASE IN
POPULATION --
THE WEEK WE HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD
HAS SOME MISTER MONA SAID --
YET THE NUMBER OF OUR
INDIVIDUALS IS CONTINUE TO RISE
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT DONE SOMETHING HAS TO BE
DONE WHEN YOU LOOK AT GREAT
STILL ME SAT.
RETENTION OF THEM OF PROVIDERS
AND AND AND EMPLOYMENT BEING A
HUGE FACTOR OF PROVIDING
SERVICES --
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO OVER THE LAST DECADE ON
AVERAGE OF INCREASED RATE OF
THREE POINT 7% ANNUALLY WE HAVE
SEEN ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW CONSUMERS.
INTRODUCED INTO THE SYSTEM.
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND ARE BEING NOW
SERVICED AND WE SHOULD EXPECT TO
SEE [inaudible]
MANY MORE.
THIS IS NOT ACCOUNTING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE NOT CURRENTLY BEING
SERVED.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S CRIMINAL
OF AND FOR NOT SERVING SOMEBODY
THAT WE DEDICATED.
OUR PROMISE WE WOULD.
HAVE BEEN RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS TO MEET DEMANDS
BUT THERE TEMPORALLY TEMPORARY
FIXES TO LONGSTANDING PROBLEMS.
AND THEY'RE ONLY VERY SEGMENTED
AUGMENTATIONS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING ABOUT
THE RESULTS FOR THE RATE STUDY.
ONCE IT IS COMPLETED I'D LIKE TO
SEE IT EVEN BEFORE MARCH IF
POSSIBLE.
WE OPEN BACK UP IN JANUARY.
LIST.
ADAM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR --
PERSONALLY ELECTED TO DELVE INTO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS REGARDING
SHELTERS AND HOUSING FOR
INDIVIDUALS ID DE.
AND I DO HAVE SOME IDEAS BEING A
FORMER GENERAL CONTRACTOR.
AFTER GERMAN OF THIS YEAR'S
LEGISLATIVE SESSION I'LL BE
WORKING HARD TO CONNECT PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ON THIS
ISSUE --
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SERIES.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
COMMITTEE HERE SOME ADDITIONAL
GOALS I WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
PROMOTE PROMOTE PUBLIC AWARENESS
ABOUT THE NEEDS AND ABILITIES OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE IDG COMMUNITY.
RECOGNIZE THE ID DE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE MADE PROFOUND CONTRIBUTIONS
TO CALIFORNIA AT ALL LEVELS OF
SOCIETY.
AND CLICK TO SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE IDT COMMUNITY IN ORDER
TO EDUCATE LEGISLATORS.
THEIR STAFFS AND STATE POLICY
MEMBERS.
AS MISTER MALONE WILL STATE AND
OR OR COLLABORATE EVERYTIME
WEARING CAUCUS I'M BEATING THE
DRUM AS HE IS ALSO.
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES ABOUT HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE.
PORT THE ID COMMUNITY.
THROUGH THAT COMING UP THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS I SELECTED
EACH INDIVIDUAL ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
SERVE BECAUSE OF THEIR PASSION%
IN WHAT THEY'VE DONE IN CAUCUS
IN IN THEIR PERSONAL LIVES OF
HOW THEY'VE HELPED COMMITTEE.
WE WANT TO STRIVE TO ALSO
SHATTER THE STIGMA SOLIS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE HAVING A
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY.
AND PROMOTE FULL COMMUNITY AND
INNER GATE INC [inaudible]
INTERROGATION [inaudible]
INTEGRATION.
AN IMPROVING EMPLOYMENT
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO YOU
INDIVIDUALS.
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE. TO TO
LEGISLATION HOME WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND INTEGRATION FOR
THE ID DE POPULATION UNTIL IT
STICKS I'M NOT GIVING UP.
WE ARE ALL [inaudible]
ONE AND WE ARE STRONGER TOGETHER.
WHEN I DID THE DYSLEXIA BILL
THREE YEARS AGO?
THEY TOLD ME NOT TO DO IT THERE
WOULD BE OPPOSITION IT WOULD
NEVER STE PASS AND I WOULDN'T
GIVE UP.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT HOW WE GOT
THAT THROUGH.
WHEN WE WERE IN COMMITTEE?
THERE WAS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MOTHERS IN THEIR LANGUAGE SHIRTS
A COMEDIAN YOU THINK THOSE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE GONNA
TELLS MAMA BEARS NO.
THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO WE
HAVE TO STICK TOGETHER.
WE AVE TO BE A FORCE OF ONE AND
WITH THIS LEGISLATURE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO AN IMPENDING --
OPPORTUNITIES WE NEED TO MOVE IN
MOVE FAST IN THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THAT
PROCESS.
I LOOK FOR THE PART PARTNERSHIP
WITH MISTER MOORE AND OUR OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE WILL BE
DOING HEARINGS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA STARTING IN SAN DIEGO.
WE DON'T HAVE THE TIME FRAME BUT
I'D LIKE TO DO SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
LOS ANGELES [inaudible]
FRESNO.
SACRAMENTO REDDING IN LOOKING
FOR THAT NORTH COAST AREAS ALSO.
AND SO THAT WE CAN TALK TO THE
FOLKS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT THIS IS MY COMMITMENT IN SIX
YEARS AYE HOPEFULLY WE'VE MADE
SOME MARKHAM REMARKABLE GAINS
MOVING FORWARD.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
ARE GOING FORWARD AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
IF YOU LOST SALARY TODAY I
APOLOGIZE.
AND IF YOU DIDN'T GOOD FREE OF
THANK YOU AGAIN AND WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE OF
COMMITTEE ORCHARD